Hosting provided by Host Tornado. They offer website hosting packages, dedicated servers, and VPS solutions. HostT.net. Programming Throwdown, Episode 23, Hadoop. Take it away, Jason. Hey, everybody. So we actually got a pretty awesome question from the audience that we want to kind of start the show with. We have an audience?
本节目由Host Tornado赞助。他们提供网站托管套餐、专用服务器和VPS解决方案。HostT.net。Programming Throwdown，第23期，Hadoop。Jason，开始吧。嘿，大家好。我们其实收到一个非常棒的听众提问，想用它来开启今天的节目。我们有听众吗？
I thought it was just you and me and our moms. So yeah, our mom had this awesome question. It was, how's it going? Wait, wait. Our mom doesn't make any sense. Oh, yeah. No. Never mind.
我以为只有你、我和我们的妈妈在听。所以，是的，我们的妈妈提出了一个很棒的问题。问题是，最近怎么样？等等，等等。我们的妈妈根本没提这事。哦，对。没事。别管了。
Your mom? This sounds like we're making bad mom jokes, but I'm not really. Yeah. I think I just dissed my own mom. Anyway, so Marco Aurelio sent in a question, and he's looking at doing some C-sharp.net coding for a website that he's interested in making. And he was sort of interested. His question was, you know, he knows that like you know server side stuff you know the
你妈妈？这听起来像是在开糟糕的妈妈笑话，但我不是那个意思。是的。我想我刚才是在贬低我自己的妈妈。总之，Marco Aurelio发来了一个问题，他正在考虑为他想做的网站编写一些C# .NET代码。他有点感兴趣。他的问题是，你知道，他知道服务器端的东西，你知道，
code and the the CPU is used on the server and so if you have you know one user you're using some amount of CPU if you have a thousand users you're using you know maybe not a thousand times but the CPU scales up right so his question is how can you big websites like is it true that big websites like eBay and Amazon and things like that, you know, run things on the server side? And how do they do that? And how does the server not explode? And then along those lines, like what languages should he focus on learning? Yeah. So, I mean, it sounds like he had a question there. He has an idea. And so his idea was to kind of build a website, but he's worried about it scaling what technology
代码和CPU是在服务器上运行的，所以如果你有一个用户，你会消耗一定量的CPU；如果你有一千个用户，你消耗的CPU，你知道，可能不是一千倍，但CPU负载会增加，对吧？所以他的问题是，像eBay、亚马逊这些大网站，它们真的在服务器端运行这些东西吗？它们是怎么做到的？服务器怎么不会崩溃？顺便问一下，他应该重点学习哪些语言？是的，听起来他确实有个问题。他有个想法。他的想法是建立一个网站，但他担心扩展性，以及他该选择什么技术。
he's going to choose yeah totally so so you i have a slightly slightly different different answer and mine is that i think sometimes in the tech community and as engineers uh you know you over engineer things so this is a classical problem and so having the issue where you can't scale your website because you're growing too fast uh would be like a very good problem to have. I mean, there are certain things you don't want to do to aggravate it, or especially if you get to the point where somebody is funding you or you're making a lot of money and your website goes down and people are depending on you. That's a really bad problem.
是的，完全正确。所以，我有一个稍微不同的答案，我的观点是，有时候在科技界，作为工程师，你们会过度设计。这是一个经典问题，所以如果你因为发展太快而无法扩展网站，那其实是一个非常好的问题。我的意思是，有些事情你不想做，以免加剧这个问题，特别是如果你已经到了有人为你投资，或者你赚了很多钱，而你的网站却宕机了，人们都在依赖你的时候。那才是一个非常糟糕的问题。
Right. But when you just have an idea, it is more important to get the idea out there, to start working on it, to find other issues like okay people I need to shift this idea slightly or I need to do this then to spend tons and tons of money trying you know like if you ever read about some of these people that started like Google you know it was two guys and some university equipment or you know Mark Zuckerberg at Facebook you know it was just like running in his dorm room off his computer right like I mean none of these things started with
没错。但当你只有一个想法时，更重要的是把想法付诸实践，开始着手去做，去发现其他问题，比如“好吧，我需要稍微调整一下这个想法”或者“我需要做这个”，而不是花大量的钱去尝试。如果你读过一些关于谷歌创始人的故事，你知道，当时就是两个人加上一些大学设备，或者像马克·扎克伯格在Facebook，你知道，就是在他的宿舍里用他的电脑运行的，对吧？我的意思是，这些东西一开始都不是
like I'm going to start with 10,000 computers and I'm going to serve millions of, I mean, that's how you go bankrupt, right? Did you know, so sorry to interject, but Stack Overflow, the website that has, you know, many questions and answers for programmers, it actually started with the two founders answering all the questions themselves.
那种“我要从一万台电脑开始，我要服务数百万用户”的规模，我的意思是，那样做你会破产的，对吧？你知道吗，抱歉打断一下，Stack Overflow，那个有很多程序员问答的网站，其实最初就是由两位创始人自己回答所有问题的。
Nice. Yeah, isn't that crazy? So they just, and I don't even, I think they were talking about it. They didn't even have a website. Like they had this form where you'd click submit, and then they would create a.html file with your question and answer. Like that's how they started.
不错。是的，这不是很疯狂吗？他们只是，我甚至觉得他们当时还在讨论。他们甚至没有网站。他们有一个表单，你点击提交，然后他们会根据你的问题和答案创建一个.html文件。他们就是这样开始的。
And now Stack Overflow is gigantic. There's like probably thousands of questions a second, right? Right, yeah. And I mean, I think even you take that example, right? So there's an idea, and you can read a lot about this. A lot has been written. And this isn't exactly an entrepreneurial show. I don't think I said that correctly. I think even you take that example, right? So there's an idea and you can read a lot about this. A lot has been written and this isn't exactly an entrepreneurial show. I don't think I said that correctly.
现在Stack Overflow已经非常庞大了。可能每秒钟都有成千上万个问题，对吧？没错，是的。我的意思是，即使你拿那个例子来说，对吧？所以有一个想法，你可以读到很多关于这方面的内容。已经有很多相关的文章了。这不完全是一个创业节目。我觉得我没说对。我想即使你拿那个例子来说，对吧？所以有一个想法，你可以读到很多关于这方面的内容。已经有很多相关的文章了，这不完全是一个创业节目。我觉得我没说对。
I think it's pretty entrepreneurial. But okay, we're kind of, okay, all right, all right. But minimally viable product, that's kind of like a word, right? So the idea there is, in fact, don't even make a backend to Jason's example here of Stack Overflow, whether it be urban legend or true, the internet shall tell away us. But, you know, if you just make a front end that looks like what the website, when people can kind of try it out and test it, you can get a ton of feedback and save yourself days, months, years of development
我觉得这挺创业的。但好吧，我们有点，好吧，好吧，好吧。但是最小可行性产品，这算是一个词，对吧？所以那里的想法是，事实上，甚至不需要像Jason提到的Stack Overflow那样去搞后端，不管是都市传说还是事实，互联网会告诉我们的。但是，你知道，如果你只是做一个看起来像网站的前端，当人们可以试用和测试时，你可以获得大量的反馈，并为你自己节省数天、数月、数年的开发
time. So that's kind of where to start. And then, um, you know, from there you can kind of, Jason will kind of address like how, how does that work? Like how does one serve millions of users a second? An hour? A day. Millions of users a day. Let's go with that. So, yeah, I mean, but to Patrick's point, just to wrap that up, even when I was making the Trivipedia, that trivia Wikipedia thing,
时间。所以这就是开始的地方。然后，嗯，你知道，从那里开始，Jason会谈谈它是如何工作的？比如一个人如何每秒服务数百万用户？每小时？每天。每天数百万用户。就这么说吧。所以，是的，我的意思是，但回到Patrick的观点，总结一下，即使我在做Trivipedia，那个琐事维基百科的时候，
I started off with just having just a flat file and you just scan through that file for everything. So if I needed to find a user by the name, I had to search through the whole file of like thousands of users or hundreds of users to find that one. There's no index. Millions of users? now there's what, like 2,000 monthly active users. And so let's say there's 100,000 users in the system. So I couldn't do that anymore. Like I couldn't just scan through all the usernames. And so I had to, you know, I ended up making ZombieDB, which is open source. And I think I posted on the podcast on G+,
我一开始只是有一个纯文本文件，你扫描那个文件来查找所有东西。所以如果我需要按名字查找用户，我必须搜索整个包含数千或数百个用户的文件来找到那一个。没有索引。数百万用户？现在有，大概2000个每月活跃用户。所以假设系统里有10万个用户。所以我不能再那样做了。我不能只是扫描所有的用户名。所以我不得不，你知道，我最终制作了ZombieDB，它是开源的。我想我在播客的G+页面上发布过关于它的消息，
on the podcast's page about that. But so I had to actually make a database. But that came months later, right? And if Trivopedia, if no one was interested in it, then I would have saved myself the trouble of having to make that database, right? And I probably saved myself the trouble of doing other things, which I would have done if there were millions of users, right? So yeah, to Patrick's point, you totally want to start small.
在播客页面上。但我确实不得不制作一个数据库。但那是几个月后的事了，对吧？如果Trivipedia没人感兴趣，那么我就省去了制作那个数据库的麻烦，对吧？而且我可能也省去了做其他事情的麻烦，如果当时有数百万用户的话，对吧？所以是的，回到Patrick的观点，你绝对想从小处着手。
Don't worry too much about your server blowing up or anything like that. But now let's answer the question from a tech standpoint. How does this work? Do all these guys like Amazon and Google and eBay, do they all just write JavaScript or do they do stuff on the server? So they do things on the server, and it works through a process called sharding. And Patrick has already helped me out here,
不要太担心你的服务器爆炸之类的。但现在让我们从技术角度回答这个问题。它是如何工作的？像亚马逊、谷歌和eBay这些家伙，他们都只是写JavaScript，还是他们在服务器上做事情？他们确实在服务器上做事情，它是通过一个叫“分片”（sharding）的过程来工作的。Patrick已经帮我解释过了，
but I'm going to take a first crack at it. Typically, you'll go to, let's say, Amazon.com. What'll happen is that'll go to a front-end server. So this server will get your request, and it'll say, and there's several front-end servers all around the globe, so you'll go to the front-end server that's closest to you. So it'll take your request, and it'll say, okay, what servers are pretty
但我打算先试着解释一下。通常，你会访问，比如说，Amazon.com。会发生的是，它会进入一个前端服务器。所以这个服务器会接收你的请求，并且全球各地有许多前端服务器，所以你会访问离你最近的前端服务器。它会接收你的请求，然后说，好的，哪些服务器比较
you know lightly loaded and the servers themselves the back-ends are constantly telling the front-end hey you know I I'm not busy or hey I'm slammed processing people's orders right so the front-end server will look for a server that's not busy and then redirect you to that server. So then your request will go through to that server, which will do all the things like query the database, see if you're logged in, do all that stuff. And keep in mind the database itself is on another server. So you have... Set of servers.
你知道，负载较轻，服务器本身，即后端，会不断地告诉前端：“嘿，你知道，我不忙”或者“嘿，我正忙着处理人们的订单”。所以前端服务器会寻找一台不忙的服务器，然后把你重定向到那台服务器。然后你的请求就会发送到那台服务器，它会做所有的事情，比如查询数据库，查看你是否登录，做所有这些事情。并且记住，数据库本身在另一台服务器上。所以你有……一组服务器。
Yeah, set of servers. And so there's this other process going on where the database has a front end, which, you know, keeps the load pretty balanced among all those database servers. And so this process of having all of these machines sort of working together and having the least used machine, you know, handling your request is what keeps websites like Amazon and eBay up and running. And a big part of doing this isn't, you know, what we're going to talk about on this show, Hadoop, is more for, like, batch processing. It's not things that you're going to do, you know, in real time when you're accepting a web request,
是的，一组服务器。所以还有另一个过程在进行，数据库有一个前端，你知道，它保持所有这些数据库服务器之间的负载相当平衡。所以这个让所有这些机器协同工作，并让使用率最低的机器处理你的请求的过程，就是让像亚马逊和eBay这样的网站保持运行的原因。而做到这一点的一个重要部分并不是，你知道，我们今天要在这个节目中谈论的Hadoop，它更多是用于，比如，批处理。它不是你在接受Web请求时会实时做的事情，
which is a big part of doing anything on the web or with big data involves sort of managing many different machines and routing work to one machine or the other. That's right. Yep. And so, I mean, yeah, and I think there exists server backend technology for many of the most common languages for people to write in. I mean, there's even Node.js, so you can write JavaScript on the backend
这是在Web上或大数据方面做任何事情的一个重要部分，涉及管理许多不同的机器并将工作路由到一台或另一台机器。没错。是的。而且，我的意思是，是的，我认为对于人们编写代码的大多数常见语言，都存在服务器后端技术。我的意思是，甚至有Node.js，所以你可以在后端编写JavaScript
and use that as a server. You know, you can just like all the major, I mean, Java, C++, I would assume C Sharp as well. I mean, there's all these things have backend pieces that you can just like all the major, I mean, Java, C++, I would assume C Sharp as well. I mean, there's all these things have back end pieces that you can write to. There's middleware kind of stuff, let's call it, that handles this load balancing and splitting. And then you write your server and your language on the back. So it's, I mean, it's slightly more than what language to use. It's kind of like understanding this underlying and the problem.
并将其用作服务器。你知道，你可以就像所有主要的，我的意思是，Java，C++，我假设C#也是。我的意思是，所有这些东西都有后端部分，你可以就像所有主要的，我的意思是，Java，C++，我假设C#也是。我的意思是，所有这些东西都有后端部分，你可以编写代码。有一种中间件之类的东西，我们称之为它，它处理这种负载均衡和拆分。然后你在后端用你的语言编写服务器。所以，我的意思是，这不仅仅是使用什么语言的问题。这更像是理解底层的原理和问题。
But you don't really know where the scaling problems gonna have until you really are kind of almost done right so something like if you think about like a slash dot let's take slash dot right so they have news stories which are being displayed but that their bottlenecks are gonna be very different than a site like eBay which is handling transactions and it's counting down auction or Amazon which has to has to handle when something sells out and they have no more and they don't want to oversell something. These things are, there's amounts of traffic,
但在你真正快完成之前，你并不知道扩展性问题会出现在哪里。所以，如果你考虑像Slashdot这样的网站，让我们以Slashdot为例，他们有正在显示的新闻故事，但他们的瓶颈将与像eBay这样的网站非常不同，eBay正在处理交易，它在倒计时拍卖，或者亚马逊，它必须处理当某样东西售罄时，他们没有库存了，他们不想超卖某样东西。这些事情，有流量，
there's hits on data. I mean, those things are going to have different bottlenecks at different amounts along the growth curve of users and on how many transactions are being handled and that kind of stuff. So, I mean, you really kind of, if you solve it too early, you risk solving the wrong problem. Yeah, that totally makes sense. So, I mean, you really kind of, if you solve it too early, you risk solving the wrong problem. Yeah, that totally makes sense.
有数据点击。我的意思是，在用户增长曲线的不同阶段，以及处理多少交易等方面，这些东西会有不同的瓶颈。所以，我的意思是，你真的，如果你太早解决它，你就有可能解决错误的问题。是的，这完全说得通。所以，我的意思是，你真的，如果你太早解决它，你就有可能解决错误的问题。是的，这完全说得通。
So, all right, well, on to our news. News. I have the first one. All right. Okay, yeah, so I'm doing the first one. I saw an article linked today on Hacker News, which is interesting, about the Fast Fourier Transform. So this is kind of like an FYI.
所以，好吧，进入我们的新闻环节。新闻。我有第一个。好的。好的，是的，所以我来做第一个。我今天在Hacker News上看到一篇链接的文章，很有趣，关于快速傅里叶变换。所以这有点像是一个信息通报。
It's not exactly news. It's not something updated. But it was a pretty good article. I kind of like a fyi it's not exactly news it's not something updated but it was a pretty good article i i kind of enjoyed reading it so i have a little bit of background with what the fourier transform is so uh without getting into the deep math uh and it's like this guy does a good job of explaining it thoroughly but not if you just kind of skim read it you know you can also kind of get the gist so four years there's code too yes and he even posts like more detailed this website's actually very interesting we'll have to take a look at more and see if there's any other articles to be really interesting to you guys or you guys just take a look and figure out on your own but he covers a wide range of topics but a four-year
这不完全是新闻。这不是什么更新的东西。但这是一篇相当不错的文章。我有点像是一个信息通报，它不完全是新闻，它不是什么更新的东西，但这是一篇相当不错的文章，我读起来挺享受的，所以我对傅里叶变换是什么有一点背景知识，所以，嗯，在不深入数学的情况下，而且这个家伙在解释它方面做得很好，但如果你只是粗略地读一下，你知道，你也可以大致了解要点，因为傅里叶也有代码，是的，他甚至发布了更详细的内容，这个网站其实非常有趣，我们以后得看看，看看是否有其他文章对你们来说非常有趣，或者你们自己看看并弄清楚，但他涵盖了广泛的主题，但傅里叶
transform and brief is going from the time domain to the frequency domain so if you have some data that over time changes so the example he uses is audio recording so you have digital samples over time and you're interested to say what are the most common or most prominent frequencies in that sound clip then you want to transform from that time data to frequency data which says you know at 80 kilohertz i don't know if that's too high i'm not good with my audio i think that's right okay 40 so okay some some number of hertz you know that this is the peak signal so like oh okay you know maybe that gives you some information or you want to do some sort of mutation of the signal and then transpose it back but this is something that's very common
变换简而言之就是从时域到频域。所以如果你有一些随时间变化的数据，他使用的例子是音频录制，所以你有随时间变化的数字采样，并且你有兴趣说，那个声音片段中最常见或最突出的频率是什么，那么你想从那个时间数据转换到频率数据，它说，你知道，在80千赫兹，我不知道那是否太高，我不擅长音频，我想那是对的，好的，40，所以好的，某个赫兹数，你知道，这是峰值信号，所以就像，哦，好的，你知道，也许这给你一些信息，或者你想对信号进行某种变异，然后把它转置回来，但这在
you'll come across a lot in a large amount of domains, image processing, audio processing. I mean, even stuff that seems completely unrelated, it can come up. But yeah. Yeah, compression of all sorts and things like that. Yeah. And this article talks about a specific kind of version of the fast Fourier transform
很多领域中非常常见，图像处理，音频处理。我的意思是，即使是看起来完全不相关的东西，它也可能出现。但是的。是的，各种压缩和类似的东西。是的。这篇文章讨论了快速傅里叶变换的一种特定版本
and also the discretized, discrete version of that. So going from math to kind of practical there and a lot of implications so it's a pretty good treatment so if you've ever heard of that and wondered what it was or trying to learn more about it um i would definitely check out this this article seemed like a pretty good description yeah it's totally awesome this is great i'll have to give this a read cool so i'm doing next article it's on the oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah oh no that's uh that's that guy who crashes through the window the kool-aid man yeah the kool-aid man the kool-aid man's coming out with a console what pretty awesome yeah hopefully it's like bullshit and you could pour but anyways so the oh yeah is coming out i'm pretty excited about it. I haven't ordered one because Patrick has scared me off of Kickstarter.
以及它的离散版本。所以从数学到实践，有很多应用，所以这是一个相当不错的处理，所以如果你曾经听说过它并想知道它是什么，或者试图学习更多关于它的知识，嗯，我绝对会看看这篇文章，它看起来是一个相当不错的描述。是的，这太棒了，这很棒，我得读一读。酷，所以我来做下一篇文章，它在哦，是的，哦，是的，哦，是的，哦，不，那是那个撞破窗户的Kool-Aid Man，是的，Kool-Aid Man，Kool-Aid Man要出一款游戏机，什么？太棒了，是的，希望它不是垃圾，你可以倒，但无论如何，哦，是的，它要出来了，我很兴奋。我还没有订购，因为Patrick用Kickstarter吓跑了我。
But I'm super interested in Oya. I still might order one off their website, even though the Kickstarter is finished. So is it available for ordering off their website? Yeah, you can actually pre-order it. Is it the same price? A little bit more? I'll find out. Oh, that's okay.
但我对Oya超级感兴趣。我可能还是会从他们的网站上订购一个，即使Kickstarter已经结束了。那么它可以在他们的网站上订购吗？是的，你实际上可以预订它。价格一样吗？贵一点点？我会查一下。哦，没关系。
But basically, you can order on the website. It comes, I think, in March or April. But it is a... For people who missed the episode on the Oya, it is a... I just had to describe it as an Android-powered console. So it's a console with a controller and all this good stuff, but it's totally Android.
但基本上，你可以在网站上订购。它会在，我想，三月或四月到货。但它是一个……对于错过Oya那一集的人来说，它是一个……我只能把它描述为安卓驱动的游戏机。所以它是一个带有控制器和所有这些好东西的游戏机，但它完全是安卓系统。
So any existing Android games, you can play using the touchpad on the controller. And any new Android games will be able to support the hardware buttons of the Oya. And it's pretty awesome because we've never had this, right? We should say it hooks up to the TV, so it's not like a phone. Oh, yeah. It's a little box that plugs into your TV, just like Xbox. Yeah, or PS3 or something.
所以任何现有的安卓游戏，你都可以使用控制器上的触摸板来玩。任何新的安卓游戏都将能够支持Oya的硬件按钮。这太棒了，因为我们从来没有过这个，对吧？我们应该说它连接到电视，所以它不像手机。哦，是的。它是一个插在电视上的小盒子，就像Xbox一样。是的，或者PS3之类的。
We've never had an open system. So a little bit of history on consoles. The way the PlayStation and Nintendo, Wii and Xbox, the way these things work is, well, unless you're Nintendo and you're awesome, but let's talk about everybody besides Nintendo. The way these work is you lose money on the console. So every time you buy a PlayStation,
我们从来没有过一个开放的系统。所以关于游戏机的一点历史。PlayStation和任天堂、Wii和Xbox的工作方式是，嗯，除非你是任天堂而且你很棒，但让我们谈谈任天堂以外的所有人。它们的工作方式是你会在游戏机上赔钱。所以每次你买一台PlayStation，
Sony loses money. Well, initially. I don't know if that doesn't normally hold true over the whole life of the console. Oh, because they're cheaper. Okay. Continue. I'm sorry. Interruption.
索尼都会赔钱。嗯，最初是这样。我不知道这在游戏机的整个生命周期中是否通常成立。哦，因为它们更便宜。好的。继续。抱歉。打断一下。
So the point is, at least they don't make a ton of money, suffice it to say. That's not the main way they make money. Right. So they actually make money by charging developers for a dev kit. So, for example, if you want to make a PlayStation 3 game, then you buy this dev kit. And the dev kit has a little bit of hardware, but I don't even know if they have hardware nowadays.
所以重点是，至少他们赚不到很多钱，这就足够了。这不是他们赚钱的主要方式。没错。所以他们实际上是通过向开发者收取开发套件费用来赚钱。所以，例如，如果你想制作一款PlayStation 3游戏，那么你就购买这个开发套件。开发套件有一点硬件，但我甚至不知道他们现在是否有硬件。
It's probably all in software or firmware. But they'll send you probably a PS3 with some special firmware. But they'll charge you for the dev kit, I think it's like $200,000 for a dev dev kit and the only reason why the price is so high is that they can recoup some of the money and the idea is you know people who buy your game are going to you know are going to give you money and you're going to give some of that money pass it along to the to the hardware manufacturer well i mean so it's worse than that, right? So, I mean, it's that for every copy sold, they have to, they put DRM on the game.
它可能都在软件或固件中。但他们可能会给你一台带有特殊固件的PS3。但他们会向你收取开发套件的费用，我想大概是20万美元一个开发套件，价格之所以这么高，唯一的原因是他们可以收回一些钱，而且想法是，你知道，购买你游戏的人会，你知道，会给你钱，然后你会把其中的一些钱传递给硬件制造商。嗯，我的意思是，情况比这更糟，对吧？所以，我的意思是，对于每一份售出的拷贝，他们必须，他们在游戏上加了DRM。
So if you don't have, but it's, I guess this is kind of almost slightly different than normal DRM, which is that if I have own media, but that media is not signed by Nintendo, I can't play my media on the Nintendo device. Right. So the, you have to go to Nintendo and they, you know,
所以如果你没有，但我猜这几乎与正常的DRM略有不同，那就是如果我拥有媒体，但该媒体不是由任天堂签署的，我就不能在任天堂设备上播放我的媒体。没错。所以，你必须去任天堂，他们，你知道，
I'm doing air quotes here. They test your software to make sure it's not going to break the console or isn't a virus or, you know, anyone,
我在这里做空气引号。他们测试你的软件以确保它不会破坏游戏机，或者不是病毒，或者，你知道，任何人，
it doesn't crash. It's good, right? And then basically with their permission, then you can turn around and you're allowed to sell that game.
它不会崩溃。这很好，对吧？然后基本上在他们的许可下，你就可以转过身来，被允许销售那个游戏。
But they, you owe them, you know, X percent or dollar amount. Oh, that's true. Per everything that you sign. Yeah. That's the most common. I think, i believe that's like a very common way yeah i think there's an initial
但他们，你欠他们，你知道，X百分比或金额。哦，那是真的。每签署一份。是的。这是最常见的。我想，我相信这是一种非常常见的方式，是的，我想有一个初始的
like like one or 200k investment just to keep like the small people out of the market and then there's also a rev share so this is talking to a friend of mine who works for ea like a long time ago so it might be different now but um but yeah so so the the the point of it is you know patrick and i can't make a game for the playstation 3 right i mean we just don't like uh have those resources at hand right so you have to be a big publisher or or nintendo has to come to you like world of goo is a common example where they're a really popular indie game um they do really well in flash and i think they were out on mobile even before the wii and then nintendo contacted them and some agreement was arranged etc um the thing about the ui is it's a completely open platform so like any game that anybody puts out for android like
比如10万或20万的投资，只是为了把小人物挡在市场之外，然后还有一个收入分成，所以这是和我在EA工作的一个朋友谈的，很久以前了，所以现在可能不同了，但嗯，但是的，所以，所以重点是，你知道，Patrick和我不能为PlayStation 3制作游戏，对吧？我的意思是，我们只是没有那些资源在手，对吧？所以你必须是一个大发行商，或者任天堂必须来找你，比如《粘粘世界》（World of Goo）就是一个常见的例子，他们是一个非常受欢迎的独立游戏，嗯，他们在Flash上做得很好，我想他们在Wii之前甚至就在移动设备上发布了，然后任天堂联系了他们，达成了一些协议等等。关于OUYA的事情是，它是一个完全开放的平台，所以就像任何人发布的任何安卓游戏一样，
trivopedia you could play it on the ui like any android program out there will run and so it's really just sort of opens up the game console experience to like to the whole world of developers and that's what's really exciting to me and the general trend has been that along those lines right so like even the xbox there's like was it xbox live arcade yeah um okay maybe i'm butchering i think playstation has something similar and we you has something similar and even maybe that we did right so the main games that you go to you know toys r us or target or best buy or i don't know where everybody goes these days whatever you're you're in your country the local equivalent is to buy buy a game right there's
Trivipedia，你可以在OUYA上玩它，就像任何现有的安卓程序一样都会运行，所以它真的只是把游戏机体验向全世界的开发者开放，这对我来说真的很令人兴奋。而且总的趋势一直沿着这些路线，对吧？所以即使是Xbox，有那个，是Xbox Live Arcade吗？是的，嗯，好吧，也许我搞砸了，我想PlayStation有类似的东西，Wii也有类似的东西，甚至可能Wii也做了，对吧？所以你去玩具反斗城、塔吉特或百思买购买的主要游戏，或者我不知道大家这些天去哪里，无论你在你的国家，当地的等价物是什么，去买一个游戏，对吧？有
those which is kind of what we're talking about but then there's these others but those still have limitations like i remember reading something about when minecraft came out for the xbox right so they had some people doing this and then they had an update and then it was like oh if they wanted to update it like a patch again you're supposed to go through all this testing again but that testing costs money so like it's like a thing like you can't they wanted to just push it early and push it often but that didn't like that was not compatible with how the money was set up and so it caused kind of a problem yeah yep totally and so sometimes people leave kind of like broken broken games because they just don't have money to to push a fix for
那些，这有点像我们正在谈论的，但还有其他一些，但那些仍然有限制，就像我记得读到关于《我的世界》为Xbox发布时的事情，对吧？所以他们有一些人在做这个，然后他们有一个更新，然后就像，哦，如果他们想更新它，像补丁一样，你必须再次通过所有这些测试，但测试需要花钱，所以就像，这是一个问题，就像你不能，他们想只是尽早发布，经常发布，但这不符合资金的设置方式，所以它造成了一种问题。是的，没错。所以有时候人们会留下那种破碎的游戏，因为他们只是没有钱去推送修复程序
it and that's bad and the other problem too is although there is an xbox live arcade there isn't a developer there's a developer ecosystem but not to the extent of these open platforms like could be yeah yeah like for example we talked on last year with that Cocos2DX which is it's not a game it's just a library that you can use to make games well for you to do that on Xbox Live Arcade I'm assuming you would have to be able to like publish like the library I'm not quite sure how that would work but on an open platform you just give all the source code and the person can take your source code and link in the Android libraries, and it just kind of works. The ecosystem is much more healthy on Android. And so this is a very positive development, right?
，这很糟糕。另一个问题也是，虽然有Xbox Live Arcade，但没有开发者，有一个开发者生态系统，但没有达到这些开放平台的程度，比如OUYA。是的，是的，比如我们去年谈到的那个Cocos2DX，它不是一个游戏，它只是一个你可以用来制作游戏的库，好吧，为了让你在Xbox Live Arcade上做到这一点，我假设你必须能够像发布库一样，我不太确定那会如何工作，但在一个开放平台上，你只需提供所有的源代码，那个人就可以拿走你的源代码并链接到安卓库中，它就直接工作了。安卓上的生态系统要健康得多。所以这是一个非常积极的发展，对吧？
So like OUYA is on track. They started shipping the developer consoles, which are very similar to the regular consoles, but already kind of like opened up so the developers can do what they need to do, run unsigned code, that kind of stuff. And so this is a positive kickstarter story yay kickstarter so hopefully they'll stay on track and early next year we'll be talking about the reviews of jason's uya console yeah totally all right so i think you have one now all right so uh future of the web the
所以OUYA步入正轨。他们开始运送开发者游戏机，这与普通游戏机非常相似，但已经有点像开放了，所以开发者可以做他们需要做的事情，运行未签名的代码，那种东西。所以这是一个积极的Kickstarter故事，耶Kickstarter，所以希望他们能保持正轨，明年年初我们就会谈论Jason的OUYA游戏机的评论了。是的，完全正确。好的，所以我认为你现在有一个。好的，所以，嗯，Web的未来，
future of the web would be html8 oh no no man Maybe that's far in the future. HTML 5? Yeah, at this rate, that's like the year 3000. It's finalized. You know, this is one of those stories. I mean, it's kind of interesting just to talk about that. I think it's kind of slow, these ratification of these things. Like, we've already kind of entered the HTML 5 zone in my mind. Like, it's generally used, right? But yet only just now did everybody kind of agree on what that meant to some extent,
Web的未来将是HTML8，哦，不，不，伙计，也许那是在遥远的未来。HTML 5？是的，照这个速度，那就像是3000年。它定稿了。你知道，这是那些故事之一。我的意思是，谈论这个有点意思。我觉得这些东西的批准有点慢。就像，在我的脑海里，我们已经进入了HTML 5区域。就像，它通常被使用，对吧？但尽管如此，直到现在大家才在某种程度上同意那意味着什么，
which still doesn't really mean anything because all sorts of reasons. But you hear this, like, remember when wireless Wi-Fi in, 802.11n was coming out, right? It was DraftN. You could buy DraftN routers. Oh, yeah, I remember that. And DraftN routers weren't guaranteed to be compatible with N.
这仍然没有任何意义，因为各种原因。但你听到这个，就像，记得当无线Wi-Fi，802.11n出来的时候，对吧？那是DraftN。你可以买DraftN路由器。哦，是的，我记得那个。而且DraftN路由器不能保证与N兼容。
And then, like, a year or two later, right, then it was like, oh, now you can get the actual N ones yeah i mean just or i remember too like c++ right even that went through this whole thing about oh we're gonna come up with a new c++ o x and it took over 10 years and then it was like finally c++ 11 or whatever it's hilarious so i mean it just sometimes we forget that like the world moves on past these standards bodies, but the standards bodies do play an important role in kind of saying like this is, you know, what HTML5 really is and really contains. But even then it's not done.
然后，像一年或两年后，对吧，然后就像，哦，现在你可以得到实际的N版本了。是的，我的意思是，或者我也记得，C++，即使是那个也经历了整个事情，关于哦，我们要想出一个新的C++ 0x，它花了超过10年，然后就像最终是C++ 11什么的，这太搞笑了。所以，我的意思是，有时我们忘记了世界已经超越了这些标准机构，但标准机构确实在某种程度上发挥了重要作用，说这就是，你知道，HTML5真正是什么以及真正包含的内容。但即使那样它也没有完成。
Like they still have other work to do to kind of make sure everything's okay. It's not like finalized doesn't mean like it's done. It means like, oh, now we can move to testing and compatibility and you know actually making it an official like html5 thing yeah it's really just almost like a social or political thing it's basically you know like let's say everyone complains about internet explorer right especially older versions of internet explorer like internet explorer 5 doesn't do what you know firefox and chrome of the same era do or maybe 5 is too old but but you see what I'm going with this so this is their way of saying you know HTML 5 is real you
就像他们还有其他工作要做，以确保一切正常。这不像定稿并不意味着它完成了。这意味着，哦，现在我们可以进入测试和兼容性，你知道，实际上让它成为一个官方的HTML5东西。是的，它真的几乎就像一个社会或政治的东西。它基本上，你知道，就像假设每个人都抱怨Internet Explorer，特别是旧版本的Internet Explorer，比如Internet Explorer 5，它不做你知道同一时代的Firefox和Chrome所做的事情，或者也许5太旧了，但你明白我的意思。所以这是他们说你知道HTML 5是真实的一种方式，你
can make content for it and if someone doesn't support it that's on them you know and and so this it's like a political thing to motivate people to switch and I'm pretty sure if you're using an old browser and you go to a And so it's like a political thing to motivate people to switch. And I'm pretty sure if you're using an old browser and you go to a website nowadays that has HTML5 content, they'll actually have a little link saying, hey, your browser is super old. You can't display this website correctly, and you should go get a new browser. Whereas before this specification was complete, they would just try and make it support everything.
可以为它制作内容，如果有人不支持它，那是他们的问题，你知道，所以这就像一个政治东西，激励人们切换，而且我很确定如果你正在使用旧浏览器，你去一个网站，现在有HTML5内容，他们实际上会有一个小链接说，嘿，你的浏览器太旧了。你不能正确显示这个网站，你应该去获取一个新浏览器。而在该规范完成之前，他们只会尝试让它支持所有东西。
Yeah, and I mean, we should say also this is by the W3C Foundation or W3C Console. I don't know what the C there is. Oh, consortium. Okay, thank you for saving me. The World Wide Web Consortium. Yes, okay. And it is a good thing.
是的，我的意思是，我们也应该说这是由W3C基金会或W3C控制台。我不知道那里的C是什么。哦，联盟。好的，谢谢你救了我。万维网联盟。是的，好的。这是一件好事。
It is, you know, that they've finalized it. And also, they've taken time to announce that they've begun the draft of HTML 5.1. Woo! Oh, man. So did they keep the peer-to-peer? HTML 5 was supposed to have peer-to-peer support. But, like, no browsers had actually implemented it to this day but i mean so basically what what that means is you could have a bit torrent client totally written in html
这是，你知道，他们已经定稿了。而且，他们还花时间宣布他们已经开始了HTML 5.1的草案。呜！哦，伙计。所以他们保留了点对点吗？HTML 5应该有对等支持。但是，就像，直到今天没有浏览器真正实现它，但我的意思是，所以基本上这意味着你可以有一个完全用HTML编写的BitTorrent客户端
like you just go to a website and you just start torrenting like on like the site you know it's just craziness and i i know i read an article where they said uh you know no browser will ever support this. Yeah, I don't know. I don't see anything about it in my research that I'm doing right now. Oh, yeah. All right. But it's OK.
就像你只是去一个网站，然后你只是开始像在网站上那样进行种子下载，你知道，这只是疯狂，而且我知道我读过一篇文章，他们说，你知道，没有浏览器会支持这个。是的，我不知道。我在我现在做的研究中没有看到任何关于它的东西。哦，是的。好的。但这没关系。
It's all right. Maybe we'll have a future topic about this. Yeah, totally. All right. So I think you're on. You're up next. Tell me about some sweet desserts. Some sweet desserts? Well, I've just been eating some raspberry pie.
没关系。也许我们以后会有关于这个的话题。是的，完全正确。好的，所以我认为轮到你了。轮到你了。告诉我一些甜点。一些甜点？嗯，我刚才一直在吃一些覆盆子派。
Oh! Yes. Been eating from the raspberry pie store been eating some raspberry pie. Oh! Yes. Been eating from the raspberry pie store. You bought raspberry pie at the store? I did. It was delicious. Yeah, it was one of those Safeway specials, but you have to have the card where they harass you,
哦！是的。一直在吃覆盆子派商店，一直在吃一些覆盆子派。哦！是的。一直在吃覆盆子派商店。你在商店买了覆盆子派？我买了。它很美味。是的，它是那些Safeway特价商品之一，但你必须有那张他们骚扰你的卡，
you know, the Safeway club card. So, like, now it's like every time I go, they want me to buy another raspberry pie. I'm like, no! No, you people! So, Patrick is like so okay so raspberry pi store um has just launched what today or a couple of days ago but it's pretty cool ideas if you own a raspberry pi device um you can go to this store you can download apps i'm assuming you
你知道，Safeway俱乐部卡。所以，就像，现在每次我去，他们都想让我买另一个覆盆子派。我说，不！不，你们这些人！所以，Patrick就像，好的，所以覆盆子派商店，嗯，刚刚推出，今天还是几天前，但这很酷，想法是如果你拥有一个覆盆子派设备，嗯，你可以去这个商店，你可以下载应用程序，我假设你
somehow transfer them to the device maybe you download them with the device itself and then you can just start using them so they have a number of free apps there's free Civ the civilization clone some other free and open-source games that are that seem to be ubiquitous like Battle of Wesnoth seems to be on every possible thing like I have Battle of Wesnoth on my gumsticks my phone like like three computers. So a lot of these open source games, it's just as soon as something new comes out, they try and get themselves on there.
以某种方式将它们传输到设备，也许你用设备本身下载它们，然后你就可以开始使用它们了，所以他们那里有很多免费应用程序，有免费的Civ，文明克隆，其他一些免费和开源的游戏，看起来无处不在，比如《韦诺之战》（Battle of Wesnoth）似乎在所有可能的东西上都有，就像我的Gumstix、我的手机上都有《韦诺之战》，就像三台电脑。所以很多这些开源游戏，一旦有新东西出来，他们就试图让自己出现在上面。
But there's a number of awesome things that you can install. Some are free, some cost money. But if you have a Raspberry Pi or if you're thinking of getting one, definitely check out the store.raspberrypi.com and see what's available. So is the Raspberry Pi the Ouya before the Ouya?
但有很多很棒的东西你可以安装。有些是免费的，有些需要花钱。但如果你有覆盆子派，或者如果你正在考虑买一个，一定要看看store.raspberrypi.com，看看有什么可用的。所以覆盆子派是OUYA之前的OUYA吗？
That's a good question, right? I mean, a lot of these are games. It's like a store and a game. I mean, it doesn't run Android, but I mean, shy of that. And it's not nice and bundled. Yeah, that's a good point. Actually, a coworker of mine,
这是一个好问题，对吧？我的意思是，很多这些都是游戏。这就像一个商店和一个游戏。我的意思是，它不运行安卓，但我的意思是，除了那个。而且它不像那样捆绑在一起。是的，这是一个好观点。实际上，我的一个同事，
I was telling him about the Android Stick PC that we talked about on the last show and how I want to get one for Christmas. And he was saying. Wait, do you really think you're going to get, I'm just like, you're going to buy one for yourself for Christmas? No. We should talk about things you want for Christmas. But like, I normally, those kinds of things is like nobody, like really? Like who's going to. So this is kind of, so my parents, ever since I was maybe like seven, they've always just asked me what I want for Christmas because they don't know anything about computers and things like that.
我告诉他关于我们在上一期节目中谈到的安卓棒式PC，以及我如何想在圣诞节买一个。他说。等等，你真的认为你会得到，我只是像，你要在圣诞节给自己买一个吗？不。我们应该谈谈你圣诞节想要的东西。但就像，我通常，那些东西就像没有人，就像真的？就像谁会。所以这有点像，所以我的父母，自从我大概七岁起，他们总是问我圣诞节想要什么，因为他们对电脑之类的东西一无所知。
So as tradition holds, my mom asked me what I wanted for Christmas. And you explained to her, like, go to this specific page. I had to give her a link. Yeah, yeah. I had to give her a tiny URL. Cool. But, yeah, so my coworker said, well, you know, if you get this, then you're stuck with Android. You should get a Raspberry Pi or a BeagleBoard or something.
所以按照传统，我妈妈问我圣诞节想要什么。你向她解释，比如，去这个特定的页面。我不得不给她一个链接。是的，是的。我不得不给她一个短网址。酷。但，是的，所以我的同事说，好吧，你知道，如果你得到这个，那么你就被困在安卓系统里了。你应该买一个覆盆子派或BeagleBoard之类的。
And that is kind of true. Like, if you get Raspberry Pi, then you have just a pure Linux shell with, you know, you could sudo app. You can install packages. You can do whatever you want. If you have Android, then you're stuck in the Android ecosystem. And so I haven't yet decided which route I'm going to go. You already sent the link, dude.
这确实是真的。就像，如果你得到覆盆子派，那么你就只有一个纯Linux shell，你知道，你可以sudo apt。你可以安装软件包。你可以做任何你想做的事。如果你有安卓，那么你就被困在安卓生态系统中。所以我还没有决定我要走哪条路。你已经发了链接了，伙计。
I haven't sent it yet. Oh. Oh, it's sitting in my saved messages but not sent in Gmail. So, yeah, I'm holding on. Okay. All right. Well, I guess we'll get an update about this. This is the last one we do.
我还没发呢。哦。哦，它在我的已保存消息中，但没有在Gmail中发送。所以，是的，我还在等。好的。好吧，我想我们会得到关于这个的更新。这是我们做的最后一个。
Sure, everyone wants to know about my mom's five. We're recording this before. Well, no, we want to find out which camp you fell into, which you decided. Not necessarily which you got for Christmas. Gotcha. But I don't know if we'll release this before or after. We're recording this before Christmas.
当然，每个人都想知道我妈妈的五。我们在之前录制这个。好吧，不，我们想找出你落入了哪个阵营，你决定了什么。不一定是你在圣诞节得到了什么。明白了。但我不知道我们会在之前还是之后发布这个。我们在圣诞节前录制这个。
That's true. Yeah, we're recording it in advance because we're both going to be gone for Christmas and New Year's. So we're recording some shows in advance. So we will find out. So we will have already known what we will have gotten. Yeah, when you guys listen to this, I'll be playing with my
那是真的。是的，我们提前录制它，因为我们俩圣诞节和新年都要离开。所以我们提前录制了一些节目。所以我们会发现。所以我们已经知道我们将得到什么了。是的，当你们听这个的时候，我会在玩我的
oh, we just caused a quantum, what is it in Back to the Future where you've broken the space-time continuum? I don't know. Anyways, yes. Time for Tool of the Show her tool of the show this is tool of the show so my tool of the show this is like the tool that I use more than anything like more hours of my day are spent using this tool than probably any other program or anything sledgehammer that's a measuring tape it's called choose now
哦，我们刚刚造成了一个量子，在《回到未来》中你打破了时空连续体是什么？我不知道。无论如何，是的。工具节目时间，她的工具节目，这是工具节目，所以我的工具节目，这就像我比任何东西都更常使用的工具，就像我一天中更多的时间花在使用这个工具上，而不是可能任何其他程序或任何东西，大锤，那是一个卷尺，它现在叫选择
so my tool of the show is emacs and uh emacs is a web editor or sorry emacs is a text editor web editor i don't know where i was going with that text editor but it is so much more than that it uh has a ton of features a ton of macros you can have uh like 20 files open in the editor at the same time and you can do well you can have infinity files open at the same time you can do things like find all occurrences of patrick and change it to gives jason a hard time in all 20 files like you could just type escape and then find replace all files or whatever so so it has a bunch of like little macro support and uh it does has all these like cool tricks it has a color theme picker you have colors so you start off with you're blowing my mind i know this is insane
所以我的工具节目是emacs，嗯，emacs是一个Web编辑器，或者抱歉，emacs是一个文本编辑器，Web编辑器，我不知道我当时要去哪里，文本编辑器，但它远不止于此，它嗯，有很多功能，很多宏，你可以有，嗯，像20个文件同时在编辑器中打开，你可以做，好吧，你可以有无限个文件同时打开，你可以做像查找所有Patrick的出现并将其更改为给Jason一个困难，在所有20个文件中，就像你可以只输入escape然后查找替换所有文件什么的，所以它有很多像小宏支持，嗯，它确实有所有这些像很酷的技巧，它有一个颜色主题选择器，你有颜色，所以你开始时，你正在震撼我的思想，我知道这太疯狂了
you start off with like a white background and black text which I just can't deal with so I picked the the clarity theme which has black text like a like a grayish like not not completely white because too much contrast like a nice soft gray coming next week Jason's favorite Emacs the and just a bunch of cool macros there's an Emacs wiki which has a ton of things to make your life easier. Like, for example, just a short anecdote. You might have something like a file which has a number, colon, and then some text. And you just want the text after the colon.
你一开始用的是白底黑字，我实在受不了，所以我选了“清晰”主题，它是黑字配一种灰灰的颜色，不是纯白，因为对比度太高了，是一种很舒服的灰色。下周会有 Jason 最喜欢的 Emacs，还有一堆很酷的宏。有一个 Emacs 维基，里面有很多能让生活更轻松的东西。比如，举个简短的例子。你可能有一个文件，里面有数字、冒号，然后是一些文本。你只想提取冒号后面的文本。
You just want to get rid of the number and the colon, right? So if you're just using Notepad, you'd have to do this by hand, line by line, right? But in Emacs, you but in emacs you just could you just do it from the shell yeah you could write like a shell script to like you know cap the file go through set and oct and things like that but in emacs you actually do like a regular expression replace like almost trivially or you could use something that had a column editor a column editor but what if it's like the colon moved to call oh that's true okay that would be bad yeah all right you didn't fully specify the problem so you get so so you can tell patrick
你只想去掉数字和冒号，对吧？如果你只用记事本，就得一行一行手动处理，对吧？但在 Emacs 里，你其实可以用 shell 来做，没错，你可以写个 shell 脚本，用 cat 读取文件，再通过 sed 和 awk 之类的工具处理。但在 Emacs 里，你实际上可以进行正则表达式替换，几乎不费吹灰之力，或者你也可以用列编辑器。但如果冒号的位置变了呢？哦，那确实，那样就不行了。好吧，你没把问题描述清楚，所以你可以告诉 Patrick。
things that emacs is for people who you know are on magic mushrooms or something come on man where are you going with this they're trying to make us lose our clean rating what is it so clean but not like what editors are you on patrick i don't edit my code man i just think it oh man like you're writing binary i just have telepathy with the computer oh it's pretty do you have all those headsets yes that was such a fad i know i wanted to get one of those things to like read your brainwaves and like hack that? I tried one in Best Buy a year or two ago and it had this like platformer game
Emacs 是给那些嗑了迷幻药之类的人用的。得了吧伙计，你这是要往哪儿扯？你是想让我们失去“纯净”评级吗？这有什么好纯净的？你到底在用什么编辑器，Patrick？我不编辑代码，伙计，我只是在想它。哦天哪，你是在写二进制吗？我只是和电脑有心灵感应。哦，这太棒了。你有那些头戴式设备吗？是的，那曾经是个非常流行的玩意儿。我知道，我当时也想弄一个来读取脑电波，然后破解它？一两年前我在百思买试过一个，它有一个平台跳跃游戏。
where if like you thought about moving right, it moved right. And I could never get it to work. But you have to train. I mean, almost all of them have always shown like you have to go through
如果你想向右移动，它就会向右移动。但我从来没能让它成功运行。但你必须进行训练。我的意思是，几乎所有这类设备都显示你需要经历一套……
a set of like exercises. Oh, yeah. Like the old dragon dictionary thing where you'd have to like translate the words you spoke or whatever or write them down. You'd have to read
一套练习。哦，是的。就像以前的龙语者（Dragon Dictation）软件，你必须翻译你说出的单词，或者把它们写下来。你得读……
like a chapter of Shakespeare to an act of Shakespeare to like train it. So that's the same thing. Like you need to go through some thing to train at least now. I did that, but maybe like I could be pretty scatterbrained. And so like I kind of think that when I was like I wasn't focusing on the training part of it. Just remember there is no game. Yeah, there is no spoon yeah there is no spoon there is no spoon so what's your tool in the show well okay so i dodged your question but i happen to
读一章莎士比亚的作品来训练它。所以是一样的道理。你需要经历一些训练过程，至少现在是这样。我试过，但我可能有点心不在焉。所以我认为当时我并没有专注于训练部分。记住，没有游戏。是的，没有勺子，是的，没有勺子，没有勺子。那么你在节目里的工具是什么？好吧，我回避了你的问题，但我碰巧……
actually be in that weird camp of nerds who thinks uh ide is is like a amazing invention of modern times where i can have 20 files open i can have have colors, and I don't need these crazy escape key combination macro. That's my camp. I do appreciate that sometimes you have to open up a shell and you have to do stuff there, or you're SSH'd into a computer. Yes, I understand. But that's like a a thing of last resort yes okay so in other words you're on the 21st century but i've just offended
实际上属于那种觉得 IDE 是现代伟大发明的怪胎阵营。我可以同时打开 20 个文件，有颜色显示，而且不需要那些疯狂的 Escape 键组合宏。这就是我的阵营。我确实承认有时你需要打开 shell 去做些事情，或者你通过 SSH 连接到一台电脑上。是的，我明白。但那是最后的手段。是的，好吧，换句话说，你活在 21 世纪，但我刚刚冒犯了……
all of our audience no i'm pretty sure i might be the only person amongst our audience who uses if you use emacs i think all right here's my thing and i'm really gonna get in trouble now but it's okay i'm gonna say anyways because that's how i roll all right um so i think people like the idea of being really really nerdy so they just say these things and they it's not they're not true like what like vi or die oh yeah i mean that's not an actual phrase i don't i just couldn't think of one but like you know like oh i only use vi for everything or like oh i only what's the there's like cult of something i don't know all these things right like oh i only use emacs everything. Or like, oh, I only, what's the, there's like cult of something. I don't know. All these things, right?
我们所有的听众。不，我很确定在我们的听众中，我可能是唯一一个使用……如果你用 Emacs，我想……好吧，这是我的看法，我现在真的要惹麻烦了，但没关系，我还是要说，因为我就是这样的人。好吧，嗯，我觉得人们喜欢那种非常非常极客的感觉，所以他们就这么说，但这些话并不是真的。比如什么“Vi 或死亡”之类的。哦，是的，那不是一个真正的短语，我只是想不出别的了。但你知道，比如“我只用 Vi 做所有事”，或者“我只用……那个叫什么来着，有个什么邪教”，我不知道这些东西，对吧？比如“我只用 Emacs 做所有事”。或者，哦，我只……那个叫什么来着，有个什么邪教。我不知道。所有这些东西，对吧？
Like, oh, I only use Emacs. And I'm sure there are people who do. And I'm sure that's legitimate. But I really feel like most people, it's not really true. Yeah. I like, same thing as like, I remember there's all these people talk to like, oh, Linux this, Linux that. And it's like, what do you run at home? Like, oh, Windows. Yeah, right.
比如，“我只用 Emacs”。我相信确实有人这么做，我也相信那是合法的。但我真的觉得对大多数人来说，这并不是真的。是的。就像我记得很多人都在谈论“Linux 这个，Linux 那个”。然后问他们在家用什么？他们说“Windows”。是的，没错。
It's like, like, I don't have a problem with that. Just like own up. Like, if somebody makes something good, it's like what do you run at home like oh windows yeah right it's like like i don't have a problem with it just like own up like if somebody makes something good it's good like don't you don't have to like oh it's made by microsoft it must be terrible yeah like oh come on i mean if it's good it's good there is a high level of zealotry with emacs and vi it's true a lot of people hate like the iphone and the ipad like oh they're terrible right and it's like in reality like okay fine you might think that but i think most people just it's oh it's because it's apple yeah it doesn't matter if like you could provably show that it was the best thing like people would still like oh it's apple it can't be good and then vice versa too other people were like oh it's not made by apple it's got to be
这就像，我对此没意见。只是承认吧。如果有人做出了好东西，就像问你在家运行什么，你说“Windows”，是的，没错。这就像，我对此没意见，只是承认吧。如果有人做出了好东西，它就是好东西，你不必非要说“这是微软做的，肯定很烂”。得了吧，如果它好，它就是好。Emacs 和 Vi 的狂热程度很高，这是真的。很多人讨厌 iPhone 和 iPad，说“它们太烂了”，对吧？但实际上，好吧，你可以这么想，但我认为大多数人只是因为它是苹果的产品。是的，就算你能证明它是最好的东西，人们还是会说“它是苹果的，不可能好”。反之亦然，其他人会说“它不是苹果做的，那肯定……
terrible yeah so i think nerds like for some reason or geeks like really fall into this trap of like like we say we want to be open-minded we want people to accept our thing but it's like in reality we try to like i think everyone is though even like you could be i had a friend growing up who's really into skateboarding and he was always like oh you have a veriflex that's a piece of crap just because it's a veriflex you know i mean so i think everybody who's like really into something has this like brand loyalty. But yeah, so the thing about tech though is tech is very functional. So like to have brand loyalty for something that doesn't necessarily have a style or the style doesn't matter.
很烂”。是的，所以我认为极客们出于某种原因真的陷入了这个陷阱，我们说我们想保持开放，我们想让人们接受我们的东西，但实际上我们试图……我觉得每个人都是这样，甚至你也可以。我小时候有个朋友非常喜欢滑板，他总是说“哦，你用的是 Veriflex？那简直是垃圾”，仅仅因为它是个 Veriflex。所以我认为每个真正沉迷于某件事的人都有这种品牌忠诚度。但是，关于科技的一点是，科技是非常实用的。所以，对于那些不一定有风格，或者风格根本不重要的东西，却有品牌忠诚度……
Like it's one thing to be like, I really like, you know, express jeans. And it's like you do it knowing that they're not going to like make you walk faster, you know. But it's like, oh, I really like Emacs. And then for Fido to oh i really like emacs and then for fido is to make the argument like emacs makes me a better coder which i don't believe then then now you're putting you know you're putting like a uh like uh you're turning something that is like a style like a personal preference into like oh i'm functionally like a better
这就像，我真的很喜欢 Express 的牛仔裤，你买它的时候就知道它不会让你走得更快。但如果是“我真的很喜欢 Emacs”，然后还要争论说“Emacs 让我是个更好的程序员”，我不相信这一点。那么现在你就是在把一种风格，一种个人偏好，变成“我在功能上是个更好的……”
program but even if people say like oh i'm more productive using emacs and an ide but their problem is like okay well like you know did you try all the ids well no did you try one did you stick with it long enough and if you kind of dig it's like a lot of times like well you know i tried it for like a week and i just couldn't stand it well i mean did you like pick up emacs and start using it hyper productively within a week no yeah like i mean i doubt it right maybe if you're like some savant i don don't know. Maybe. But like, no. Okay, anyways, my tool of the week is Chrome Browser Sync. It's pretty awesome. It's not really like a tool of the week. It's totally a tool of the week.
程序员。但即使人们说“我用 Emacs 比用 IDE 更高效”，他们的问题在于，你试过所有的 IDE 吗？没有。你试过一个吗？你坚持用得够久吗？如果你深挖一下，很多时候是因为“我试了一周，实在受不了”。我的意思是，你拿起 Emacs 就能在一周内变得超级高效吗？没有。我怀疑，对吧？也许如果你是个天才，我不知道。也许吧。但没有。好吧，总之，我本周的工具是 Chrome 浏览器同步。它非常棒。它其实不算是一个“周工具”。它绝对是一个周工具。
I totally copped out on all these. It's okay. So I really like this. No, your Snapseed tool was awesome. I'm still using that. Oh, good. I downloaded it during the show. And you said one of our other tool of the week you were still using.
我完全是在敷衍这些。没关系。所以我真的很喜欢这个。不，你的 Snapseed 工具很棒。我还在用它。哦，太好了。我在节目期间下载了它。你说你还在用我们之前的另一个周工具。
Yeah, I'm still using KeePass. Yeah. So your tools are a winner. All right. All right. Better than Emacs using. Yeah, I'm still using KeePass. Yeah, so your tools are a winner. All right, all right. Better than Emacs. All right. I'm so in trouble. I extend the olive branch and I get my hand cut off.
是的，我还在用 KeePass。是的。所以你的工具是赢家。好吧，好吧。比 Emacs 好用。是的，我还在用 KeePass。是的，所以你的工具是赢家。好吧，好吧。比 Emacs 好用。好吧，我惹大麻烦了。我伸出橄榄枝，结果手被砍掉了。
I'm sorry. All right, anyways. So Chrome browser thing, if you don't know, Chrome is a browser made by Google. Yep. And one feature that I've been using Chrome, and I like it I mean
抱歉。好吧，总之。所以 Chrome 浏览器同步，如果你不知道的话，Chrome 是谷歌制作的浏览器。是的。我一直在用 Chrome 的一个功能，我很喜欢它，我的意思是……
but I like Chrome and one feature that I've decided I really like is across my devices that if you have Chrome and you sign into it which
但我喜欢 Chrome，我决定我真的很喜欢的一个功能是，它可以在我的设备间同步。如果你有 Chrome 并登录了它，这……
I mean we can get to all the debate but alright whatever so you sign into it and it'll synchronize your bookmarks it'll synchronize you can see what tabs
我的意思是我们可以进行所有这些辩论，但不管怎样，你登录了它，它就会同步你的书签，它会同步……你可以看到你在其他电脑上打开了哪些标签页。
are open from your other computers. It's a really good feature. I think now, as somebody was pointing out, Firefox ships it by default or it's an add-on or something. I don't remember. But that browser sync functionality, and whatever browser, I happen to use Chrome,
这是一个非常好的功能。我想现在，正如有人指出的那样，Firefox 默认就带这个功能，或者是一个插件之类的。我不记得了。但那种浏览器同步功能，无论什么浏览器，我碰巧用的是 Chrome，
so that's my tool of the week. But they may all have it by now. Yeah, browser sync is awesome. Turn it on. It's awesome. It even works with mobile. Right, so on my iphone i have the chrome and i can look at what oh what was that page i was looking up on my computer at home and i just go like my home computer and like oh that tab you know bring it open it's amazing like especially i notice it a lot when i'm using directions like i'll be at home and i'll look up directions for a place and then i don't want to
所以这就是我本周的工具。但现在它们可能都有这个功能了。是的，浏览器同步太棒了。打开它吧。它很棒。它甚至可以在手机上用。没错，在我的 iPhone 上我有 Chrome，我可以查看我在家里的电脑上查过什么页面，我只要点一下我的家用电脑，然后“哦，那个标签页”，打开它，这太神奇了。特别是当我用导航的时候，我会在家里查好路线，然后我不想……
like i mean it's not a big deal to retype in the address But it's so much easier to just pull up your phone and say show me my desktop tabs and the directions are there like done Ready to go. How do you enter all those key combinations for Emacs on your phone? Okay Escape key okay i'm done the last one i'm done escape key i'm done i'll imagine if there was an emax editor for the phone how hard that would be just a custom keyboard yeah that's true you'd need a keyboard that had like control s or something like i'm sorry i'm done with the joke anyways browser all right that's pretty fun time for book of the show. Book of the show.
我的意思是，重新输入地址也不是什么大事。但直接拿出手机说“显示我的桌面标签页”，路线就在那里，这太方便了，搞定。你在手机上怎么输入 Emacs 的那些组合键？好吧，Escape 键，好吧，我完了，最后一个，我完了，Escape 键，我完了。想象一下如果手机上有一个 Emacs 编辑器，那会有多难？只是一个自定义键盘。是的，那确实，你需要一个有 Control-S 之类按键的键盘。抱歉，我开玩笑开完了。总之，浏览器，好吧，这很有趣，节目书单时间。节目书单。
That was pretty awesome, Echo. Okay, I'll go first. You went first last time. Did you write that in Emacs or was that a script on Audacity? I wrote it in C sound. In C sound. Okay, you guys can look that up later. Because you didn't get the joke.
那太棒了，Echo。好吧，我先来。上次是你先来的。你是用 Emacs 写的，还是 Audacity 里的脚本？我是用 Csound 写的。在 Csound 里。好吧，你们以后可以去查查。因为你们没听懂这个梗。
Should I go first? No, you go first. So I don't have programming. Jason is going to be related to our topics. That's why he's going to go second. Okay. So I like sci-fi, science fiction. Totally.
我先来吗？不，你先来。我没有编程。Jason 的书会和我们的主题相关。这就是为什么他要第二个来。好吧。所以我喜欢科幻小说。完全喜欢。
And fantasy as well. This one, it's science fiction, but it kind of, yeah, a little bit of fantasy kind of as well. But mostly science fiction. And that is Anathem. This is a book by Neil Steven stevenson it's really long like i mean the whole time i've warned you i thought that i thought that i misread this and i thought it was anthem by ayn rand i thought that's where you're going with this okay anathem by neil stevenson and um it's it's a really long book i don't I think it's like bordering on like a thousand pages or something oh wow so here
还有奇幻小说。这一本，它是科幻小说，但它也有一点点奇幻的感觉。但主要是科幻。那就是《Anathem》。这是尼尔·斯蒂芬森写的一本书。它真的很长，我的意思是，我一直警告你，我以为我读错了，我以为是安·兰德的《Anthem》。我以为你要说的是那个。好吧，《Anathem》，尼尔·斯蒂芬森写的，它是一本非常长的书，我不觉得，我觉得它大概有一千页左右。哦哇，所以这里……
the paperback is 981 pages so it's really long but it's really good so this is gonna sound like Patrick why is this the best book you have to stick it out
平装本有 981 页，所以它真的很长，但它真的很好。所以这听起来会像“Patrick，为什么这是最好的书？”你必须坚持读完……
through the first couple hundred pages first couple hundred pages are a little bit rough but it is worth it it's like a huge investment but like when you make
前几百页。前几百页有点难读，但它是值得的。这就像一项巨大的投资，但当你做出……
the investment of like oh okay what's going on here it's really good I don't want to do any spoilers about what the so farther part of the story but it starts off and you're in a monastery and it just starts describing like a whole world which is like slightly different than ours and like you kind of begin to pick up that there's some things which are different but kind of the same and it just just like really, Neil Stevenson just goes into like great detail about like all the functioning of this monastery. And it's not, lest you get confused,
“哦，好吧，这里发生了什么”的投资时，它真的很好。我不想剧透故事的后续部分，但它开始时你是在一个修道院里，它开始描述一个完整的世界，它和我们的世界略有不同，你开始意识到有些东西不同，但又有点相似。尼尔·斯蒂芬森真的非常详细地描述了这个修道院的所有运作方式。而且，为了不让你困惑，
it's not like a religious monastery like you would think of today or in kind of our world. So you kind of got to stick with it and see it's something slightly different. Again, I'm trying not to give away because some people really want to have all that surprise of the book.
它不像你今天或我们世界里想的那种宗教修道院。所以你得坚持读下去，看看它有什么不同。同样，我尽量不剧透，因为有些人真的想保留书中的所有惊喜。
So I don't want to give more than even the back cover would say but i'd check it out it's really good um and like i said you gotta stick it out for the first little bit um it got good reviews yeah it's a little you gotta you just know you're gonna read the whole book like just commit like i'm gonna read this whole book and it's only 11 bucks that's not bad i mean that's like, what, a Santa page? Yeah. So, I mean, you can get on, you know, e, the Kindle or whatever through Amazon here is like $6. Oh, even better. And it's good, you know.
所以我不想说得比封底介绍的更多，但我会去看看，它真的很好。嗯，就像我说的，你得坚持读完开头的一点点。它评价很好。是的，你得知道你要读完整本书，就像承诺一样，“我要读完这本书”，而且只要 11 块钱，那还不错。我的意思是，那是什么，一页一分钱？是的。所以，我的意思是，你可以在亚马逊的 Kindle 上买到，大概 6 块钱。哦，更好。而且它很好，你知道。
Or even the mass market paperback. I don't know what the difference is. It's only $9. Oh, right. So, okay. We're sitting here like reading Amazon prices on the air. This is fascinating podcasting. But check it out.
或者大众平装本。我不知道有什么区别。只要 9 块钱。哦，好吧。我们坐在这里在广播里读亚马逊的价格。这真是迷人的播客。但去看看吧。
It's a really good book. I mean, I really like it. And if anybody has read it or does read it after this recommendation, like, let us know. Like, any of the books. Oh, that's a good point. So for people who bought the book of the previous show and people who buy this book, et cetera. Or already have it or whatever. Yeah, or already have it.
这是一本非常好的书。我的意思是，我真的很喜欢它。如果有人读过它，或者在这次推荐之后读了它，请告诉我们。任何书都行。哦，那是个好点子。所以对于那些买了上一期节目推荐的书的人，以及买这本书的人，等等。或者已经有这本书的人，等等。是的，或者已经有的人。
You know, if you like the book or if you hate the book, let us know. Yeah, I'd be curious to see if you have a better book. Let us know. Post on G+. Or if you hate this whole segment. If you hate the show, post on G+. Some people might be like, oh, Head First Design Patterns is decent,
你知道，如果你喜欢这本书，或者讨厌这本书，告诉我们。是的，我很好奇你们有没有更好的书。告诉我们。在 G+ 上发帖。或者如果你讨厌整个环节。如果你讨厌这个节目，在 G+ 上发帖。有些人可能会说，“《Head First 设计模式》还不错，
but I also really like this other design pattern book. Feel free to post on the G+, and start a thread where you're only going to help out the rest of the community by contributing. If you want to leave a really horrible comment about what we should be fixing on iTunes, that's cool. Rate it five stars, because those are the community by contributing. Yeah, and if you want to leave a really horrible comment about what we should be fixing on iTunes, that's cool. Rate it five stars because those are the ones we read. And then just, like, tear it up.
但我更喜欢这本设计模式书”。欢迎在 G+ 上发帖，开启一个话题，你只会通过贡献来帮助社区的其他成员。如果你想在 iTunes 上留下关于我们应该修复什么的非常糟糕的评论，那也行。给它五星好评，因为那些是……通过贡献来帮助社区。是的，如果你想在 iTunes 上留下关于我们应该修复什么的非常糟糕的评论，那也行。给它五星好评，因为那是我们读的评论。然后随便怎么喷都行。
It's fine. Yeah, if you rate it five stars, then we'll mark it as useful. There we go. Just kidding. Okay. All right, sorry. So that's Anathem by Neal Stephenson. Anathem with an extra A.
没关系。是的，如果你给五星好评，那我们就会把它标记为有用。就是这样。开个玩笑。好吧。好吧，抱歉。所以这就是尼尔·斯蒂芬森的《Anathem》。Anathem，多了一个 A。
I mean, I'm pretty sure that's how you say it. I'm not exactly sure. No, you're right. Yeah, well, it's definitely not Anthem because that's missing an A. So my book is Hadoop, The Definitive Guide. And I've actually been reading this book for a while now, trying to sort of understand more of the Hadoop internals and the way Hadoop does different things on the backend.
我的意思是，我很确定这就是它的读法。我不完全确定。不，你是对的。是的，好吧，它绝对不是 Anthem，因为那个少了一个 A。所以我的书是《Hadoop：权威指南》。我其实读这本书有一段时间了，试图去理解更多 Hadoop 的内部原理，以及 Hadoop 在后端处理不同事情的方式。
So as somebody who – I feel like I can call myself a MapReduce expert. I might get destroyed for that by somebody who's a crazy expert. But I know a ton about MapReduce. I work a lot with MapReduce and Hadoop internals and things like that. So you just set yourself up. You know that, right? Yeah, I know. I'll bring it on. I feel like I can take it I accept the challenge unless we get like Jeff Dean or Sanjay
所以作为一个……我觉得我可以称自己为 MapReduce 专家。我可能会被某个疯狂的专家摧毁。但我对 MapReduce 了解很多。我经常使用 MapReduce 和 Hadoop 内部原理之类的东西。所以你这是给自己挖坑。你知道吧？是的，我知道。放马过来吧。我觉得我能应付，我接受挑战，除非 Jeff Dean 或 Sanjay……
Gemawatt the original creators of MapReduce unless they comment that would be awesome yeah I could take abuse from them I'd be worth it so you guys that would be programmingthrowdown at gmail.com or on our G Plus page.
Gemawatt，MapReduce 的原始创造者，除非他们评论，那会很棒。是的，我愿意接受他们的批评，那很值得。所以你们，那是 programmingthrowdown@gmail.com 或者在我们的 G+ 页面上。
Any of you want to say anything? Go ahead. So I feel like I've been doing a lot with MapReduce. We could have them on the show to argue with you. Oh, yeah. We should see. They're in the Bay Area somewhere. Okay.
你们谁想说什么吗？请便。所以我感觉我在 MapReduce 上做了很多工作。我们可以请他们上节目和你辩论。哦，是的。我们应该看看。他们就在湾区的某个地方。好吧。
Yeah. All right. So this book, even as somebody who does a lot of MapReduce and Hadoop, the book is incredibly useful. It's a great reference. It has a lot of examples. It really quickly answers the question, why do you use Hadoop, which we'll hopefully answer ourselves. But it explains it in a lot of detail.
是的。好吧。所以这本书，即使对于像我这样经常使用 MapReduce 和 Hadoop 的人来说，这本书也非常有用。它是一本很好的参考书。它有很多例子。它很快就能回答“为什么要使用 Hadoop”这个问题，我们希望我们自己也能回答这个问题。但它解释得非常详细。
And it has a ton of extra content. So if you like this show and you're interested in Hadoop and things we talk about, this has a ton of great examples. And it's got a cool elephant on the cover dude it's pretty epic it must be awesome now do you know why it has an elephant on the cover i think so hadoop is the name of the creator's pet elephant toy yeah like his his child's elephant oh his child's okay yeah so so it wasn't created by a five-year-old whose pet elephant he named Hadoop. That would be epic. That would be pretty awesome. It would be the most epic five-year-old ever.
而且它有很多额外的内容。所以如果你喜欢这个节目，并且对 Hadoop 和我们谈论的事情感兴趣，这里有很多很棒的例子。而且封面上有一只很酷的大象，伙计，它太史诗了。它一定很棒。你知道为什么封面上有一只大象吗？我想是因为 Hadoop 是创造者宠物大象玩具的名字。是的，就像他孩子的象。哦，他孩子的，好吧。所以它不是由一个五岁小孩创造的，他把宠物大象命名为 Hadoop。那会很史诗。那会是史上最史诗的五岁小孩。
That was you as a five-year-old. Oh, I wish. Okay, on to our programming language. Hadoop. Okay, so I have to caveat that. I said programming language. It's not really a programming language. No, it's...
那五岁时的你。哦，我希望是。好吧，进入我们的编程语言。Hadoop。好吧，我得声明一下。我说的是编程语言。它其实不是编程语言。不，它是……
Hadoop. But that's okay because I noticed our title isn't Programming Language Throwdown. Oh. It only hit me this week. That's totally true. Is that weird? We've been doing 23 of these episodes now,
Hadoop。但没关系，因为我注意到我们的标题不是“编程语言 Throwdown”。哦。我这周才意识到。这完全是真的。这很奇怪吗？我们现在已经做了 23 期节目了，
and it never hit me. When we named the show, we talked about programming languages, but really the title is Programming Throwdown. So, I mean, we're totally in our wheelhouse here. You could definitely throw down Hado versus like versus all reduce or spark or some of these other you know frameworks there's definitely there's a throwdown to be had here you already threw it down with emacs now throwing down
我从来没意识到。当我们给节目命名时，我们谈论的是编程语言，但实际上标题是“Programming Throwdown”。所以，我的意思是，我们完全在我们的专业领域内。你绝对可以把 Hadoop 和 MapReduce 或 Spark 或其他一些框架进行 Throwdown（对决）。这里绝对有一场对决。你已经用 Emacs 对决过了，现在又对决……
that you're an expert on hadoop let's bring it yeah get her done so hadoop it's not even that late did i tell you i'm actually getting no no we gotta say i'm real quick okay all right i'm getting a bib so uh i want to get a bib for a baby like the kind your hose hooks up to on the faucet no no like the kind where like they puke and it lands on the thing like that they wear whatever i want to get one of those and i want it to say for you for me and i it to say For you For me And I want it to say I ate and made Hadoop I'm just getting the stare down from Patrick
说你是 Hadoop 专家，来吧。是的，搞定它。所以 Hadoop，现在还没那么晚。我告诉你我其实正在……不，不，我们得快速说一下。好吧，好吧，我正在买一个围兜。所以，我想给婴儿买一个围兜，就是那种连接到水龙头上……不，不，就是那种他们吐奶时会落在上面的那种，他们戴着的那种，不管怎样，我想买一个，我想让上面写着“为了你，为了我”，我想让它写着“我吃了，做了 Hadoop”。我只是收到了 Patrick 的凝视。
I don't get it I'll write it in Emacs Let me think about it If I start laughing in a few minutes Okay Well it ends in OOP Is it a poop joke? Yes it is a poop joke
我不明白。我会用 Emacs 写下来。让我考虑一下。如果几分钟后我开始笑。好吧，它以 OOP 结尾。这是一个关于大便的笑话吗？是的，这是一个关于大便的笑话。
Okay now I'm getting a different kind of stare. It's like a despondence. Okay, so let's give some history on Hadoop. Hadoop was based on MapReduce, which was something created by, as I mentioned, Jeff Dean and Sanjay Gemawat at Google. So they created something called MapReduce. They wrote out a paper explaining how MapReduce works. And then Doug Cutting, who is another engineer somewhere in the Bay Area,
好吧，现在我收到了另一种凝视。这就像一种沮丧。好吧，让我们介绍一下 Hadoop 的历史。Hadoop 基于 MapReduce，正如我提到的，这是 Jeff Dean 和 Sanjay Gemawat 在谷歌创造的东西。所以他们创造了名为 MapReduce 的东西。他们写了一篇论文解释 MapReduce 是如何工作的。然后 Doug Cutting，湾区的另一位工程师，
I think he made a startup. Is that right? Yeah, and he was working on an open source version of it. He was inspired by the paper. He began working on it. And then at some point, Yahoo either bought his team or he joined Yahoo. That was sometime around 2006-ish. And so then he kept working on it while he was at Yahoo.
我想他创办了一家初创公司。对吗？是的，他当时正在开发它的开源版本。他受到了那篇论文的启发。他开始着手开发。然后在某个时候，雅虎要么收购了他的团队，要么他加入了雅虎。那大约是在 2006 年左右。所以他在雅虎工作时继续开发它。
So he actually, the whole reason why he created Hadoop was because he wanted to support Lucene, which is an open source reverse index. And we actually talked about Lucene in the mailbag episode of this show, answering the question posed by the person who wanted to create his own, like he wanted to index the web for Magic the Gathering. So yeah, Lucene is a reverse index meant for indexing thousands, millions of pages. And Hadoop was something that Doug wrote to support that. So at the time, it was kind of meant for that and it was sort of myopic but
所以他其实创造 Hadoop 的全部原因是因为他想支持 Lucene，这是一个开源的反向索引。我们其实在节目的邮件袋环节谈论过 Lucene，回答了那个想创建自己的索引的人提出的问题，他想为《万智牌》索引网络。所以是的，Lucene 是一个旨在索引成千上万、数百万页面的反向索引。而 Hadoop 是 Doug 为了支持它而编写的东西。所以当时，它有点是为了那个目的，而且有点短视，但是……
since then it's been uh it's grown like it's an amazingly large scale how big the last uh the largest hadoop file system that we know of is run by facebook and it is a hundred petabytes do you know how much a petabyte is more than a terabyte how much more than a terabyte a hundred a thousand ten thousand that reminded me of that monty python where he's like blue i mean yellow no so yes a petabyte is a thousand terabytes so all you guys have like a terabyte hard drive at home so a thousand of those that's what a hundred thousand of them well yeah you're right it has to be more than that a hundred thousand petabytes a hundred thousand terabytes wouldn't it be it would be a hundred petabytes a hundred oh right all right yeah so facebook has a hundred
从那以后它已经……它成长了，它是一个惊人的大规模系统。我们所知的最大的 Hadoop 文件系统是由 Facebook 运行的，它有 100 PB。你知道 1 PB 是多少吗？比 1 TB 多。比 1 TB 多多少？一百、一千、一万？这让我想起了那部《巨蟒剧团》，他就像“蓝色，我是说黄色，不”。所以是的，1 PB 是 1000 TB。所以你们所有人可能家里都有一个 1 TB 的硬盘，所以 1000 个那样的，这就是 10 万个……好吧，你是对的，它必须比那更多。10 万 PB，10 万 TB，难道不是吗？它应该是 100 PB。100，哦，好吧，好吧，是的，所以 Facebook 有 10 万……
thousand um of those of those hard drives that that they're using to store all the data at least so it might be it might be replicated that's true right i mean that's just one and that's only that's only what they've owned up to they may have bigger yeah that's true they may be lying right like it might be actually be smaller yep or it could even be like that you know somebody else has one that's like you know just way bigger and they just don't want to talk about i mean this stuff's uh it's a competitive advantage yeah yeah that's true it's true okay so you want to discuss some of the features? What are the things that... One thing we should mention in the beginning is
……个那样的硬盘，他们至少用它们来存储所有数据。所以它可能是……它可能是被复制的，那是真的，对吧？我的意思是那只是一个，而且那只是他们承认的。他们可能有更大的。是的，那是真的，他们可能在撒谎。是的，它可能实际上更小。是的，或者它甚至可能是……你知道，别人有一个更大的，他们只是不想谈论。我的意思是这些东西是……这是一种竞争优势。是的，是的，那是真的，那是真的。好吧，所以你想讨论一些功能吗？有哪些事情……我们一开始应该提到的一件事是……
Hadoop has become almost like an umbrella term. Hadoop is the MapReduce for doing this distributed processing, but people also refer to Hadoop as this collection of tools, with Hadoop being one of the things in
Hadoop 已经几乎变成了一个伞形术语。Hadoop 是用于进行这种分布式处理的 MapReduce，但人们也把 Hadoop 称为这种工具集合，而 Hadoop 本身是其中的一部分……
Hadoop which is really confusing let's talk about some of the other features similar tools that come with Hadoop also changing my answer again I was being silly it's 1024 right isn't it because isn't it a power of two yeah you're right we have no idea what we're doing oh man, man. So, yeah, there's... So, okay, so let's do a little bit first. MapReduce. Okay. We use this term a little prematurely. So what is MapReduce?
在 Hadoop 中，这真的很令人困惑。让我们谈谈其他一些功能，随 Hadoop 一起提供的类似工具。再次改变我的答案，我刚才是在胡闹。是 1024，对吧？难道不是吗？因为它不是 2 的幂吗？是的，你是对的，我们根本不知道我们在做什么。哦天哪，天哪。所以，是的，有……所以，好吧，让我们先做一点点。MapReduce。好吧。我们有点过早地使用了这个术语。那么什么是 MapReduce？
So, yeah, I'll try and explain MapReduce. Yeah, that's a good point. So, first of all, let's do a little bit about distributed computing. Back in the day, people used to do, and they still do, but people used to be totally consumed with MPI and things like that. MPI stands for message passing interface. And so if you had a lot of data and you
所以，是的，我会试着解释 MapReduce。是的，那是个好点子。所以，首先，让我们谈谈分布式计算。在过去，人们过去常常做，现在也还在做，但人们过去完全沉迷于 MPI 之类的东西。MPI 代表消息传递接口。所以如果你有很多数据，并且……
wanted to do something with that data, you would break the data up into pieces. Then you would pass each piece to a different computer. And then the computers would probably like send you back some results and you would put the results together um and then if you sent if you pass the message to the computer and it died your whole process would blow up well you would have to have code to handle it yeah or you had to say oh this machine died so i need to like pass the message to somebody else and so you have to be, oh, this machine died, so I need to pass the message to somebody else. And so you had to be completely consumed
你想用这些数据做些什么，你会把数据分成几块。然后你会把每一块传给不同的电脑。然后电脑可能会把一些结果传回给你，你会把结果放在一起。嗯，如果你传了……如果你把消息传给电脑，而它死机了，你的整个进程就会崩溃。好吧，你必须有代码来处理它。是的，或者你必须说“哦，这台机器死机了，所以我需要把消息传给别人”。所以你必须是……“哦，这台机器死机了，所以我需要把消息传给别人”。所以你必须完全沉迷于……
with all of these meta things that didn't really matter to solving what you wanted to solve. So it turns out that not every problem can be what's called embarrassingly parallel, where you just send chunks of data to different machines. But almost all algorithms can be implemented using something called MapReduce. And so the idea is you take your data,
所有这些对解决你想解决的问题并不真正重要的元事物。所以事实证明，并非每个问题都可以是所谓的“尴尬并行”，即你只是把数据块发送到不同的机器。但几乎所有的算法都可以使用所谓的 MapReduce 来实现。所以这个想法是，你获取你的数据，
you break it up into chunks, then for each chunk, you execute a map on the chunk, which takes this chunk of data, could be a sentence on a web page, or it could be a URL, or it could be any atom of data, and then returns a key-value pair. So for example, let's say you wanted for every word on the internet and it could scan through that page and then spit out a bunch of key value pairs where the key is the word and the value is the number of times you saw it on that page so if you saw like the Fox jumped over the dog then there's two thus so one of your key value pairs
你把它分成块，然后对于每一块，你在块上执行一个 map，它获取这块数据，可能是网页上的一个句子，或者是一个 URL，或者可以是任何数据原子，然后返回一个键值对。所以例如，假设你想为互联网上的每一个单词……它可以扫描那个页面，然后吐出一堆键值对，其中键是单词，值是你在这个页面上看到它的次数。所以如果你看到像“狐狸跳过了狗”，那么有两个“the”，所以你的一个键值对……
would be the comma two. Another one would be fox comma one, etc. So now all of these key value pairs generated by all these mappers, they're all kind of floating somewhere in your cluster. So you have something called a shuffle that takes all of the keys that are in common and all the key value pairs that have the same key and squishes them together. So if you have 10 websites with Fox as the key, you'll just have one key with Fox. And then instead of a value, now you'll have a list of values, where that list is how many times Fox was seen on all these websites. Then you have, that's the shuffle phase.
会是“the, 2”。另一个会是“fox, 1”，等等。所以现在所有这些由所有这些 mapper 生成的键值对，它们都漂浮在你的集群中的某个地方。所以你有一个叫做 shuffle 的东西，它获取所有相同的键，以及所有具有相同键的键值对，并将它们挤在一起。所以如果你有 10 个网站以“fox”为键，你只会有一个以“fox”为键的条目。然后不再是一个值，现在你将有一个值列表，其中该列表是“fox”在所有这些网站上被看到的次数。然后你有……那是 shuffle 阶段。
Then you have the reduce phase, where you collapse that key list of values down to one answer. So in this example, you would take Fox and then 2, 1, 2, 1, 2, 3, 2, 4, and you would add up all those numbers together. And you would say for Fox, for the whole Internet, it's whatever, 13 million or something like that. And the cool thing about this is that all these pieces can happen in parallel like the part that collapses all of the fox values and the part that collapses all the bear values could happen on two different machines and the part that scans website a and scans website b can happen on two different machines and uh it all just kind of works and so as long as you're and the mapuce code also handles all these things like,
然后你有 reduce 阶段，在那里你把那个键值列表折叠成一个答案。所以在这个例子中，你会取“fox”，然后是 2, 1, 2, 1, 2, 3, 2, 4，你会把所有这些数字加在一起。你会说对于“fox”，对于整个互联网，它是多少，1300 万之类的。这个东西很酷的地方在于所有这些部分都可以并行发生，比如折叠所有“fox”值的部分和折叠所有“bear”值的部分可以在两台不同的机器上发生，扫描网站 A 和扫描网站 B 的部分可以在两台不同的机器上发生，而且……它一切都运行得很好。所以只要你是……而且 MapReduce 代码也处理所有这些事情，比如……
oh, the machine that was processing Fox dies. We need to send Fox to another machine. They've dealt with all that for you, so you don't have to do it. So that's a short summary of MapReduce. And Hadoop is an open source version of this. All right. So, I mean, part of this is going to be if you're going to – you kind of started with something that was a little bit presumptuous, dare I say,
“哦，正在处理‘fox’的机器死机了。我们需要把‘fox’发送到另一台机器。”他们已经为你处理了所有这些，所以你不必自己做。所以这就是 MapReduce 的简短总结。而 Hadoop 是这个东西的开源版本。好吧。所以，我的意思是，这部分将是如果你要……你一开始就有点自以为是，我敢说，
which is you start with everybody reading all the tasks, reading one page of the Internet. Where do you store something that's every page of the Internet? You can't just, like, store that, liketfs or you know ext you know you know a file partition like this i mean so big yeah well not only the size large but the number of files is ridiculous oh yeah right so you could run into problems so i mean one thing that has to go along with this is you have to have a distributed file system so first of all you can't house all the data on one computer right but then on top of that even like how you would access it in a way that is efficient so that you can have these
那就是你从每个人阅读所有任务，阅读互联网的一页开始。你把互联网的每一页存储在哪里？你不能只是像存储在 tfs 或者你知道 ext，你知道一个文件分区里，这……我的意思是太大了。是的，好吧，不仅大小很大，而且文件数量也很荒谬。哦，是的，没错。所以你可能会遇到问题。所以我的意思是，必须伴随这个的一件事是，你必须有一个分布式文件系统。所以首先，你不能把所有数据都放在一台电脑上，对吧？但除此之外，即使是你访问它的方式，也必须是高效的，这样你才能有这些……
tens hundreds thousands millions of map threads working on this you need a way to be able to retrieve that quickly and reliably and in a sharded manner so that you know that can take place very quickly and and they've handled that as well with the hadoop file system yep totally yep so the uh the hadoop file system uh operates in 64 megabyte chunks and that chunk could have one file in it it could have a piece of a file it could have 10 000 files in it if the files are very small and so versus you know a regular file system which uses you know b trees and redblack trees and things like that, this uses something totally different that's meant for gigantic files, millions of tiny files, all of these things. And it expects you to access the files using something like Hadoop
成千上万、数百万的 map 线程在上面工作。你需要一种能够快速、可靠且以分片方式检索它的方法，这样你知道这可以非常快地发生。而且他们也用 Hadoop 文件系统处理了这一点。是的，完全正确。是的。所以 Hadoop 文件系统以 64 MB 的块运行，那个块可以有一个文件，它可以有一个文件的一部分，如果文件非常小，它可以有 10,000 个文件。所以相比于（你知道）常规文件系统，它使用（你知道）B 树和红黑树之类的东西，这使用了一种完全不同的东西，它是为巨大的文件、数百万个微小文件、所有这些东西设计的。而且它期望你使用像 Hadoop 这样的东西来访问文件，
versus a file system which doesn't really know how you're going to access the files. There's also HBase. HBase is a column oriented database written in Hadoop. So you know whereas HDFS is a file system, HBase is a database. So if you need to you know get rows by key and if you need to find all keys where the first name is this, if you need to do all the secondary indices, all that stuff, but you still need the distributed coolness from HDFS, which HBase is built on, then you can use HBase and get that.
而不是一个并不真正知道你将如何访问文件的文件系统。还有 HBase。HBase 是一个用 Hadoop 编写的面向列的数据库。所以你知道，虽然 HDFS 是一个文件系统，但 HBase 是一个数据库。所以如果你需要（你知道）按键获取行，如果你需要找到所有名字为这个的键，如果你需要做所有的二级索引，所有这些东西，但你仍然需要来自 HDFS 的分布式酷炫特性（HBase 是建立在它之上的），那么你可以使用 HBase 并获得它。
So all this code that's running, I mean, if we begin to talk about hundreds, thousands of servers or even more, I don't know how high you could go, how high do you want to go, I guess, you're going to have to have a way to keep this. So machines are going to die. If you talk about that many machines and some of this data can take a long time to process,
所以所有这些正在运行的代码，我的意思是，如果我们开始谈论成百上千台服务器甚至更多，我不知道你能达到多高，你想达到多高，我想，你将不得不有一种方法来保持这个。所以机器会死机。如果你谈论那么多机器，并且其中一些数据可能需要很长时间来处理，
I mean, machines are going to die. You might want to add new machines. You want to increase your capacity. I mean, that would be a huge mess in the olden days. I mean, imagine if you're doing MPI and you have to deal with that, right? I mean, it would take you months to have to deal with the, oh, this machine died, so I'm going to send it to that machine, right? I mean, that could be such a nightmare, right?
我的意思是，机器会死机。你可能想添加新机器。你想增加你的容量。我的意思是，那在过去的日子里会是一团糟。我的意思是，想象一下如果你在做 MPI，你必须处理那个，对吧？我的意思是，你需要几个月的时间来处理“哦，这台机器死机了，所以我得把它传给那台机器”，对吧？我的意思是，那可能是一场噩梦，对吧？
Or what if the machine that's sending the things dies? I mean, you don't want to have to restart the whole thing just because of that. So dealing with that, right? That could be a nightmare. And so Hadoop's thing which handles that is called Zookeeper, going along the lines of pet animals and things like that. And so, yeah, Zookeeper is a distributed coordination service. And so in really short, what that means is somebody can write some data to Zookeeper, and somebody else, if they try to write data
或者如果发送东西的机器死机了呢？我的意思是，你不想仅仅因为那个就重启整个事情。所以处理那个，对吧？那可能是一场噩梦。所以 Hadoop 处理这个的东西叫做 Zookeeper，沿着宠物动物之类的路线。所以，是的，Zookeeper 是一个分布式协调服务。所以简而言之，这意味着有人可以向 Zookeeper 写入一些数据，而其他人，如果他们试图写入数据，
and the data collides, Zookeeper sort of figures all that out. So if two machines both want to take the same job at the same time, Zookeeper says, no, look, only one of you guys get this job. Things like that. So like we said,
并且数据发生冲突，Zookeeper 会把所有这些都搞定。所以如果两台机器都想在同一时间接同一个工作，Zookeeper 会说，“不，看，你们中只有一个能得到这个工作”。诸如此类的事情。所以就像我们说的，
I mean, Hadoop is kind of, when people talk about it, they're kind of talking about all these kind of tools, which are kind of all necessary to get together and enable you to be able to run those MapReduces. And so, I mean, kind of now talking about the strengths, one of the things that we talked about is you bring up more computers, great. You can have more threads and the threads can run sooner. They don't have to be serialized yep and so i mean it really you can just scale this dot dot dot yeah like just you know whatever like however much i guess time or money you have determines uh you know how big you can go or you need to go or have to go yeah yeah it's amazing i mean you could be on using the amazon web services
我的意思是，Hadoop 某种程度上，当人们谈论它时，他们谈论的是所有这些工具，这些工具对于协同工作并让你能够运行那些 MapReduce 任务是必不可少的。所以，我的意思是，现在谈到它的优势，我们讨论的一点是，你可以增加更多的计算机，太棒了。你可以拥有更多的线程，线程可以更快地运行。它们不必串行化，是的，所以我的意思是，你真的可以扩展它……是的，就像你知道的，无论你拥有多少时间或金钱，都决定了你能做多大，或者你需要做多大，或者必须做多大。是的，这太神奇了，我的意思是你可以使用亚马逊网络服务。
which run hadoop right so they have a a version that they've altered i guess or changed elastic elastic map reduce or whatever right yeah right which is is very similar yeah so they have a they have their version which runs on their infrastructure so they have so like you know for instance they may not i don't i think the way it works and and I'm speaking a little out of my expertise here, but it's, you know, instead of having, like, a Hadoop file system, they have their version of the same thing, right? Their elastic file storage, which they kind of hide from you, so you don't have to worry about it. You just put data there. And you can run the Elastic MapReduce, which runs on that. So, it's very similar and shares a lot of stuff with Hadoop, but it's not, isn't exactly the same.
它们运行 Hadoop，对吧？所以他们有一个他们修改过的版本，我想或者是改变了，Elastic MapReduce 之类的，对吧？是的，没错，非常相似。所以他们有运行在他们基础设施上的版本，所以他们，比如，举个例子，他们可能不会……我想它的工作方式，虽然我在这方面的专业知识有限，但它不是像拥有一个 Hadoop 文件系统，他们有他们自己的版本，对吧？他们的弹性文件存储，他们把它隐藏起来了，所以你不必担心它。你只需要把数据放进去。然后你可以运行 Elastic MapReduce，它就在上面运行。所以，它非常相似，与 Hadoop 共享很多东西，但并不完全相同。
Yeah, yeah, totally. I don't know if it uses the same API or how that works. I don't know. Yeah. I didn't look into that. No, yeah, I haven't done that with Amazon. But the other cool thing is it's fault tolerant. So, you know, all these crazy corner cases that you'd have to code up yourself,
是的，完全正确。我不知道它是否使用相同的 API 或者它是如何工作的。我不知道。是的，我没有深入研究过。不，我没有在亚马逊上做过那个。但另一个很酷的事情是它具有容错性。所以，你知道，所有那些你必须自己编写代码处理的疯狂极端情况，
they've done that for you. And they'll even do crazy things that you wouldn't think about doing. But, like, one thing Hadoop will do is let's say you have 20 machines that are in your little hadoop cluster right and you're running a job and you and hadoop detects the zookeeper detects you're only running one job and the job had eight workers like eight you know let's say there's eight mappers so hadoop will say well you know if one of these machines dies you have to like start the whole thing over again. So let's just run like since you only have eight, let's just duplicate all this work, like run it on two machines. And if one of them dies, it's OK.
他们已经为你做好了。他们甚至会做一些你根本想不到的疯狂事情。但是，比如 Hadoop 会做的一件事是，假设你的小型 Hadoop 集群中有 20 台机器，你正在运行一个作业，Hadoop 检测到——Zookeeper 检测到你只运行一个作业，而且该作业有 8 个工作节点，比如 8 个 Mapper，所以 Hadoop 会说，好吧，如果其中一台机器挂了，你必须重新开始整个过程。所以我们干脆运行……既然你只有 8 个，我们就把所有这些工作复制一下，在两台机器上运行。如果其中一台挂了，也没关系。
Or another thing they'll do is they'll know, oh, you know, you might be able to like pass some data or you might be able to arrange and do a little bit of the reducing in the mapper. Like these crazy optimizations that we don't really think about because we're too busy focused on the algorithm, they've done all that grunt work, you know, and they've done all these awesome optimizations. Sort of like using C++ instead of assembly, right? Exactly the same. Yeah, like MPI is so low that like you just have to end up doing
或者他们会做的另一件事是，他们知道，哦，你可能能够传递一些数据，或者你可能能够安排并在 Mapper 中进行一点归约（reducing）。就像这些我们不太考虑的疯狂优化，因为我们太忙于专注于算法本身，他们已经完成了所有繁重的工作，你知道，他们已经做了所有这些很棒的优化。有点像用 C++ 代替汇编，对吧？完全一样。是的，就像 MPI 太底层了，你最终不得不做
like way too much and that feeds into one of the features i i skipped over that that you were particularly a little bit passionate about crunch oh yeah so you want to talk about crunch patrick's actually used used crunch quite a bit yeah well you overstayed sir i i i am not so emblazonedly boldened to say that. But, okay. Not to call you a liar, but I'll just... Okay. So what Crunch is, is Crunch allows you to, instead of having to use the kind of off-the-shelf nature of a lot of the stuff that MapReduce does
太多工作了，这引出了我跳过的一个你特别感兴趣的功能，Crunch。哦，是的，你想谈谈 Crunch？Patrick 实际上用过不少 Crunch。是的，好吧，你过奖了，先生。我不敢那么大胆地说。但是，好吧。不是说你是骗子，但我只是……好吧。所以 Crunch 是什么，Crunch 允许你，而不是必须使用 MapReduce 所做的很多那种现成的东西
or kind of fit into their paradigm, kind of even going again on what Jason said extending it even a little further even more flexibility in how you do these things and just allow the computer to handle it right the computers to handle it just so you take care of this right so crunch is an API for allowing you to add an even higher level
或者那种适应他们的范式，就像 Jason 刚才说的，甚至更进一步，在做这些事情时有更多的灵活性，只需让计算机来处理它，对吧？让计算机来处理它，你只需要负责这个，对吧？所以 Crunch 是一个 API，允许你添加一个更高级别的
say like here's generally the data flow I want and here's the operations I want to perform and alright go and so um if you if you kind of drew out like oh i need the data these two data things need to flow together i need to do some operation on them and then once that's done i make some calculation and then i need that to flow with another piece of data you know and then i want to kind of join those together in like an inner join fashion or something right like all these kinds of notions could become they're like multiple map reduce hadoop jobs that we need to run and there are
比如，这是我想要的大致数据流，这是我想要执行的操作，好了，去吧。所以，如果你画出类似“哦，我需要数据，这两个数据需要流在一起，我需要对它们进行某种操作，一旦完成，我进行一些计算，然后我需要它与另一块数据流在一起”，你知道，然后我想以内部连接（inner join）的方式将它们连接起来，或者类似的东西，对吧？所有这些概念都可以变成……它们就像我们需要运行的多个 MapReduce Hadoop 作业，并且有
you know things that you might have to string together very carefully but crunch allows you to just kind of specify like these are the way i wanted to do and it'll handle like oh i could merge these two together and run them at the same time um Or, oh, I need to spin up a new Hadoop run for this thing or for that thing. And it kind of allows you to do that much more simply and easily and in a way that's flexible, just allowing the computer to handle it. Yeah, yeah. And Crunch feels more like Java, you know, because you have these like P tables,
你知道，你可能必须非常小心地串联起来的事情，但 Crunch 允许你只是指定，比如，这些是我想要做的方式，它会处理，比如“哦，我可以把这两个合并在一起，同时运行它们”，或者，“哦，我需要为这个东西或那个东西启动一个新的 Hadoop 运行”。它允许你更简单、更容易地做到这一点，而且方式很灵活，只需让计算机来处理它。是的，是的。而且 Crunch 感觉更像 Java，你知道，因为你有这些像 PTable 一样的东西，
which are basically like they feel a lot like hash maps in java so you can kind of take your existing java code and if you need it to run on like a thousand machines you know it's not just a copy paste or you can't just change hash map to p table there's more to it than that but it it it um it has things like get all the values like get a list of all the values that exists in hash map and also in Ptable. And so it kind of feels more like you're just doing native Java. So it's good for people who want to get started with Hadoop
它们基本上感觉很像 Java 中的哈希映射（hash maps），所以你可以利用现有的 Java 代码，如果你需要它在比如一千台机器上运行，你知道，这不仅仅是复制粘贴，或者你不能仅仅把哈希映射改成 PTable，这不仅仅是那样，但它有像“获取所有值”这样的功能，比如获取哈希映射中存在的所有值的列表，PTable 中也有。所以它感觉更像是你在做原生的 Java。所以对于那些想开始使用 Hadoop 的人来说，这很好，
and aren't used to writing this kind of stuff. Yeah, so that idea like Ptable or PgroupTable and it allows you to say like, oh, and everything in that, you know, in parallel do this thing, right? Like go through and perform some operation. So that's what I was kind of talking about, maybe a little too high of a level. But that's how you kind of, it gives you this API,
而且不习惯写这种东西。是的，所以那个像 PTable 或 PGroupTable 的想法，它允许你说，哦，那个里面的所有东西，你知道，并行地做这件事，对吧？比如遍历并执行一些操作。所以我刚才谈论的就是那个，可能有点太高层了。但这就是你如何……它给了你这个 API，
but it really is kind of almost classes and things that make it just look like, to Jason's point, it looks like you're writing Java code on some fancy hash map. And in reality, you're instructing Crunch to in the back end figure out how to arrange the map reduces and the to be able to do that yeah totally totally so there are some weaknesses to map reduce no um i know after we sang the praises you think it would be just a panacea that would just be a
但它实际上几乎是类和一些东西，使它看起来，用 Jason 的话来说，看起来就像你在一些花哨的哈希映射上写 Java 代码。实际上，你是在指示 Crunch 在后端弄清楚如何安排 MapReduce，并能够做到这一点。是的，完全正确。所以 MapReduce 确实有一些弱点。不，我知道在我们唱赞歌之后，你以为它会是一个万能药，
cure-all but no uh one of the problems with map produce is it takes a long time to spin up and spin down. And so what we mean when we say that is spin up refers to, for example, let's say you're building a multi-threaded program. So the first thing you'll do is make the thread pool and actually ask the operating system for the threads. So that's kind of like our spin up time, right? And so to ask the operating system for some threads happens in what? Milliseconds? Maybe even less than that, microseconds. But to ask MapReduce for 100 machines to do work on or to ask a Hadoop Zookeeper for 100 machines is going to take on the order of seconds at least. I mean, it really just depends on your cluster, but it's not going to take Miller or microseconds, right? So if you have, you know, a Mabry's job that adds two numbers, like goes through two files and then adds the numbers together and the files are a meg each, you might just want to do that in C++, you know, because by the time you spin up the machines, you know, send little, send numbers to the machines and, you know, then compute the result and then store the results somewhere.
但不是。呃，MapReduce 的问题之一是启动和关闭需要很长时间。所以当我们说这个时，启动指的是，例如，假设你正在构建一个多线程程序。所以你要做的第一件事是创建线程池，并实际向操作系统请求线程。所以这有点像我们的启动时间，对吧？所以向操作系统请求一些线程需要什么？毫秒？甚至可能更少，微秒。但是向 MapReduce 请求 100 台机器来工作，或者向 Hadoop Zookeeper 请求 100 台机器，至少需要几秒钟的时间。我的意思是，这真的取决于你的集群，但它不会是毫秒或微秒，对吧？所以如果你有一个 MapReduce 作业，它把两个数字相加，比如遍历两个文件然后把数字加在一起，而文件每个只有 1 兆，你可能只想用 C++ 来做，你知道，因为当你启动机器，发送数字到机器，然后计算结果，然后把结果存储在某处时，
Yeah, your C++ program would have run like 40,000 times or something. So there is a problem there. Yeah, there is something called worker pools. And the idea is, you know, if I have a job that I want to run over and over again, I can sort of prep Hadoop and I can say, look, Hadoop, you're going to do this thing a hundred times. So get ready for that. And then it'll do some optimizations there.
是的，你的 C++ 程序可能已经运行了 4 万次之类的。所以那里有一个问题。是的，有一种东西叫工作池（worker pools）。这个想法是，你知道，如果我有一个想反复运行的作业，我可以预先准备 Hadoop，我可以对它说，看，Hadoop，你要做这件事一百次。所以为此做好准备。然后它会在那里做一些优化。
Also, we talked about all these wonderful things of bringing on new computers and bringing down computers and all these stages and divide it and just, oh, do this little bit of work and then do this little bit of work. And that helps it be really scalable. But I mean, as you can imagine,
此外，我们谈到了引入新计算机和移除计算机的所有这些美妙之处，以及所有这些阶段，划分它，然后，哦，做这一点点工作，然后再做这一点点工作。这有助于它真正具有可扩展性。但我的意思是，正如你可以想象的那样，
all the data that's in your program, all those class and everything need to be able to be serialized out and then when they're read back in they need to be deserialized and sometimes you know oh it can be said like oh i'm going to do this on the same machine but a lot of times you have to do it anyways because you don't know like oh am i going to be doing this on the same chart or not or is it going to go somewhere else yeah and so it's just a life if that takes a long time because you have especially some nasty intricacies it could be a problem but even just in general like that's going to be overhead yeah and then the other thing and there's some theoretical reasons why this is true that i'm not going to get into because it takes a long time but
程序中的所有数据，所有那些类和一切都需要能够被序列化出来，然后当它们被读回时，它们需要被反序列化，有时你知道，哦，它可以说，哦，我要在同一台机器上做这个，但很多时候你无论如何都必须这样做，因为你不知道，哦，我是在同一个分片上做这个，还是它会去别的地方。是的，所以如果这需要很长时间，那简直是……因为你特别有一些讨厌的复杂性，这可能是一个问题，但即使只是通常情况下，那也会有开销。是的，还有另一件事，而且有一些理论原因说明这是真的，我不打算深入探讨，因为它需要很长时间，但是
but there's excessive there's a lot of materialization so you know each of your mappers going back to our word account example each of those things that scans one page of the web has to put those results all those key value pairs on disk on that hadoop file system and then the reducer the the shuffler sorry that's putting together all the keys has to read those from disk and then put the reduced key values lists on disk and then the reducer has to read from disk and then put the reduced key values lists on disk and then the reducer has to read from disk and then put the answer on disk right if you were just writing some C++ program you would just put everything in memory
但是有过度……有很多物化（materialization），所以你知道，你的每个 Mapper，回到我们的单词计数示例，扫描网页每一页的那些东西，都必须把那些结果，所有那些键值对，放在磁盘上，放在那个 Hadoop 文件系统上，然后 Reducer，那个 Shuffle 程序，抱歉，它正在把所有的键放在一起，必须从磁盘上读取它们，然后把归约后的键值列表放在磁盘上，然后 Reducer 必须从磁盘读取，然后把答案放在磁盘上，对吧？如果你只是在写一些 C++ 程序，你会把所有东西都放在内存里，
or maybe you would only put you know a bit of that on disk like one stage of that on disk so there's a lot of disk. when you're using Hadoop. There are some tools to sort of make Hadoop a little easier to use. One of them is Pig. Pig and Hive. And so they're good for if you don't want to have to write Hadoop, like raw Hadoop code, you can just put your data in Hive or put your data in a flat file like a text file then you use something like pig or hive they have their own programming
或者你可能只会把其中的一部分放在磁盘上，比如其中的一个阶段放在磁盘上，所以使用 Hadoop 时会有很多磁盘操作。有一些工具可以让 Hadoop 使用起来稍微容易一些。其中之一是 Pig。Pig 和 Hive。所以它们很好，如果你不想写 Hadoop，比如原始的 Hadoop 代码，你可以直接把数据放进 Hive，或者把数据放进一个平面文件，比如文本文件，然后你使用像 Pig 或 Hive 这样的东西，它们有自己的编程
languages which are much more terse than Hadoop yeah I mean with a lot of these things that's planning can take a long time even it's like figuring out like oh how how exactly do I want to divide my data what yeah you know getting my data into the right place in the right format you know that can take a it can take a lot of time. Yeah, totally. And so these tools will help you with that. Yep.
语言，比 Hadoop 简洁得多。是的，我的意思是，对于很多这些事情，规划可能需要很长时间，甚至包括弄清楚，哦，我到底想怎么划分我的数据，什么……你知道，把我的数据放到正确的地方，以正确的格式，你知道，这可能需要……它可能需要很多时间。是的，完全正确。所以这些工具会在这方面帮助你。是的。
So we have Avro. I have no idea what that does, so that's going to be all you, buddy. Oh, Avro is like Thrift. It's like a serialization thing. Oh, okay, okay. Yeah, yeah. We already talked about this. Yeah, totally.
所以我们有 Avro。我不知道那是做什么的，所以那全靠你了，伙计。哦，Avro 就像 Thrift。它就像一个序列化工具。哦，好的，好的。是的，是的。我们已经谈过这个了。是的，完全正确。
I'm reading your points. So what is Hadoop used for uh so what is hadoop used for what is map produce used for everything everything everything i think there was a in the white paper on the original white paper on map produce they said that it was i don't remember i think it was over half of computations at google were part of a MapReduce. I think it was some very large number. Oh, interesting. But yeah. So, and Google is like a huge company. So, you know, and I think I'm pretty sure Facebook and all these companies have probably similar statistics. It's kind of interesting to see what companies will say what, right? It's kind of like a
我正在读你的要点。所以 Hadoop 是用来做什么的？呃，所以 Hadoop 是用来做什么的？MapReduce 是用来做什么的？一切，一切，一切。我想在关于 MapReduce 的原始白皮书中，他们说，我不记得了，我想谷歌超过一半的计算都是 MapReduce 的一部分。我想那是一个非常大的数字。哦，有趣。但是是的。所以，而且谷歌是一家大公司。所以，你知道，而且我想我很确定 Facebook 和所有这些公司可能都有类似的统计数据。看看哪些公司会说什么，这很有趣，对吧？这有点像一个
little bit of a game, like, oh, hey, we're doing this. Well, we're doing, you know, but you know, it's like's like who knows like how what percentage of the actual value those things are they're just like kind of one-upping each other yeah but only like slightly and others are just keeping quiet in the corner and it's like oh are they embarrassed or like do they like oh this is this is ridiculous i'm just laughing right like yeah it's kind of interesting but i mean no seriously i mean map reduce it pops up all over the places like um you know even for even for doing, like, image processing. Like, oh, you want to, like, do a whole bunch of, you know, look for objects in something.
小游戏，比如，哦，嘿，我们在做这个。好吧，我们在做，你知道，但你知道，这就像谁知道这些东西的实际价值占比是多少，他们只是在某种程度上互相攀比。是的，但只是稍微一点点，而其他人只是安静地待在角落里，就像，哦，他们是尴尬吗？或者他们就像，哦，这太荒谬了，我只是在笑，对吧？是的，这很有趣，但我的意思是，不，说真的，我的意思是 MapReduce，它出现在各个地方，比如，呃，你知道，甚至用于做，比如，图像处理。比如，哦，你想，比如，做一大堆，你知道，在某物中寻找物体。
Or you want to run the same little algorithm on things. I mean, people have done MapReduce to do that. People have done MapReduce even for, like, I saw one guy who was writing a little bit of a tutorial. Like, I think he was trying to convert, like, old PDFs and, like, do OCR on them. Like, he had a whole bunch of them. Each page of old books that had been scanned was either just an image or a PDF. You wanted to do OCR on all of them and then put them somewhere. But you could imagine if you have millions and millions of these pages, it would just be a nightmare to figure out a C++ framework and structure or Java structure to do that. That could just take a long time.
或者你想在事物上运行同一个小算法。我的意思是，人们已经用 MapReduce 来做那个了。人们甚至用 MapReduce 来做，比如，我看到一个人在写一个小教程。比如，我想他试图转换，比如，旧的 PDF，并对它们进行 OCR。比如，他有一大堆。被扫描的旧书的每一页要么只是图像，要么是 PDF。他想对所有这些进行 OCR，然后把它们放在某处。但你可以想象，如果你有数百万页这样的页面，要弄出一个 C++ 框架和结构或 Java 结构来做这件事简直是一场噩梦。那可能需要很长时间。
But that's right in the wheelhouse of map reduce yeah yeah totally yeah there's a ton of things you can do with map reduce the biggest thing is you know especially as sort of like let's say you're an indie developer you're developing writing code out of your house right but you want to do really big data kind of things like for example let's say you have a website you have a few thousand people on your website and you're capturing all their clicks and things like for example let's say you have a website you have a few thousand people on your website and you're capturing all their clicks and things like that let's just take so your website is a thousand people a day and each person click like on average there's a thousand people and each person clicks once a minute so there's how many minutes in a day I don't know
但这正是 MapReduce 的拿手好戏。是的，是的，完全正确。是的，你可以用 MapReduce 做很多事情。最重要的事情是，你知道，特别是作为，比如，假设你是一个独立开发者，你在家里写代码，对吧？但你想做真正的大数据之类的事情，比如，举个例子，假设你有一个网站，你的网站上有几千人，你正在捕获他们所有的点击和类似的东西。比如，举个例子，假设你有一个网站，你的网站上有几千人，你正在捕获他们所有的点击和类似的东西，让我们假设你的网站每天有一千人，每个人点击……比如平均有一千人，每个人每分钟点击一次，所以一天有多少分钟？我不知道，
let's just say they click once in a day okay so you have a thousand clicks a day that's still 30,000 clicks a month so if you wanted to go back through a year's worth of data that's what 365,000 clicks that's a lot of data and so you know you don't even want to do that on your machine because it's going to take forever so if you wrote a map reduce you could say um you know run it on your machine on like one day's data make sure it works and then say look amazon you know you have this elastic cloud that's totally awesome you know chug on this data like run this map reduce that i wrote and you know amazon i'll charge you however much that costs maybe five bucks or something or you do it accidentally the wrong way and then do you do that? I don't know.
让我们假设他们一天点击一次，好吧？所以你一天有一千次点击，那一个月仍然有 3 万次点击。所以如果你想回顾一年的数据，那是多少？36.5 万次点击，那是很多数据。所以，你知道，你甚至不想在你的机器上做那个，因为它会花费永远的时间。所以如果你写了一个 MapReduce，你可以说，嗯，你知道，在你的机器上运行它，处理一天的数据，确保它能工作，然后说，看，亚马逊，你知道，你有这个完全棒极了的弹性云，你知道，处理这些数据，比如运行我写的这个 MapReduce，然后，你知道，亚马逊会向你收取无论多少费用，也许五块钱之类的，或者你意外地以错误的方式做了它，然后你做了那个？我不知道。
You just accidentally misconfigured something and it's really big. It's like some really outlandishly large number. You probably can set a budget, I'm sure. I'm sure. All of a sudden, now you can run that same program on a thousand computers that
你只是意外地配置错误了一些东西，而且它真的很大。这就像一些非常离谱的大数字。我敢肯定，你可能可以设置一个预算。我敢肯定。突然之间，现在你可以在一千台计算机上运行同一个程序，
you don't have to own. It's pretty awesome. I think that's a wrap for this episode. Yeah. Hadoop is great. Learn it. It's fantastic. We hope you will have or will have had a good Christmas. Oh, yeah, that's right. Yeah. In the future, we hope Christmas will be awesome. Will have been awesome. Will have been awesome. That's pretty, pretty wild. i don't know all right till next time see you later the intro music is axo by biner pilot programming throwdown is distributed under a creative commons attribution share alike 2.0 license you're free to share copy distribute transmit the work to remix adapt the work but you must provide attribution uh to uh patrick and i
你不需要拥有它们。这太棒了。我想这一集就到这里了。是的。 Hadoop 很棒。学习它。它太棒了。我们希望你已经或将会有一个愉快的圣诞节。哦，是的，没错。是的。在未来，我们希望圣诞节会很棒。将会很棒。将会很棒。那真是太疯狂了。我不知道。好吧，下次见，回头见。片头音乐是 Biner Pilot 的 Axo。Programming Throwdown 在知识共享署名-相同方式共享 2.0 许可下分发。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输作品，以重新混合、改编作品，但你必须提供署名，呃，给 Patrick 和我，
and uh share alike in kind There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
以及，呃，相同方式共享。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。